afterwards airs on book tv every
saturday at 10 pm and sunday at 9 00 pm
eastern you can watch all previous
afterwards programs on our website
booktv.org
and now on book tv we're live with
author and investigative journalist
annie jacobson
ms jacobson is the author of four books
including area 51 the pentagon's brain
and the newly released phenomena the
secret history of the u s government's
investigations into extra sensory
perception and psychokinesis
annie jacobson live on in-depth for the
next three hours starts now
annie jacobson let's start with some
definitions what is area 51
area 51 is that secret base out in
nevada where all kinds of mysterious
things happen
that you and i can talk about and maybe
we know what's going on out there maybe
we don't why is it called area 51
big debate i believe it's called area 51
because of the original project that
went on out there in 1951
information given to me by some of the
sources that i
interviewed at length for that
that book but of course
everything about area 51 is kind of a
puzzle inside of a puzzle so
that's even debated
the actual origins the original date the
origin story of area 51. so 1951 what
was going on
the atomic energy commission was doing
lots of nuclear testing out there in the
middle of the
desert and
they wanted to
you know keep what they were doing
secret and the cia was kind of coming
into existence with its programs and the
two merged in this idea of if you have a
secret base inside of a secret place you
can do secret programs so this was not a
military operation necessarily
well area 51 has every
organization you can imagine there over
the decades military intelligence
community atomic energy commission
so everybody has their foot in area 51 i
think
what is operation paper clip what was
operation paperclip ah well
so i get the ideas of my books from the
books i've written before
and when i was finishing up area 51
i learned quite a bit about some nazi
scientists who were here working on
programs and i found this fascinating in
particular a fellow by the name of
siegfried nehemiah okay now nehemiah was
a very important
air force
uh technical intelligence person
and when he retired in the 70s he was
given the defense department's
distinguished civilian service award so
that's kind of this incredibly high
honor to get from the pentagon
and when i looked into his past i
learned that he had been her during the
war during world war ii he had been
one of the most important
uh technical intelligence officers for
herman goring of the luftwaffe and he
was given the highest award that you
could be given there and i thought
how does this happen how do you work for
one side
and then work for the other side and
that is why i wrote operation paper kit
that was the springboard of that of that
journey into that you know narrative
story but what was operation paperclip
it was to bring nazi scientists to the
u.s correct yes after the war we brought
as many as sixteen hundred nazi
scientists uh to create our weapons
programs and
you know this is something that really
is brings up a lot of moral questions
and what i what i found most intriguing
about writing that book as a journalist
perhaps with all my books is
trying to maintain this neutral position
and
looking at both sides of the argument
because
you know many people will tell you
paperclip was imperative
we had to bring those nazi scientists to
the united states in order to beat back
the russians others will tell you
how could we have possibly brought these
you know nazis here some of them were
war criminals
there's you know dod weapons policy for
you in a nutshell i.e
extremely complicated and always
you know two sides of the argument
what is the pentagon's brain
the pentagon's brain uh book number
three for me um
okay so that idea came from paperclip
when my editor
i was finishing up with paperclip and
warner von braun is probably the most
famous
operation paperclip scientist um
created our rocket program and then you
know really responsible for the apollo
program in many regards
and he was a nazi scientist he had been
hitler's rocket builder um v2s yes yes
and my editor at little brown asked me
when i was finishing up paperclip
what it what what went on with von braun
in such and such a year and i looked
into it and found out that
this was in 1957
that this new agency was emerging at the
pentagon and it was called arpa the
advanced research projects agency we now
know it as darpa with a d for defense
but when they were beginning this
organization
uh you know the query was which who's
the best scientist in america to lead
this program to lead all of american you
know military technology in in blue
what's called blue sky research and they
chose von braun and they you know he he
was interviewed for the job but his
caveat to take the job was yes i'll take
it but i i need to bring 12 of my
colleagues from the rocket program and
they were all former nazis so kind of
that was the dividing line for the
pentagon they said no
and they passed on von braun being
uh darpa's first director and
you know but the but the way that uh it
came about of calling it the pentagon's
brain was really realizing that the
defense department is looking at the
great minds
that's what they're concerned with they
want to know
who will lead us in technology of the
future
what are some of the things that have
come out of darpa
i mean you name it i mean the most
famous is of course the internet which
was originally called the arpanet
but technologies like gps
laser weapons um
you know
there's no end to what the pentagon
produces
uh you there there's reason to say that
artificial intelligence is a
darpa product um
biotechnology
so
there is the the idea that the pen
this is important to think about
darpa is the most powerful and most
productive military science agency in
the world
and so few people know about it that's
pretty much why i wrote the book in a
nutshell because it was like
how can this agency be so significant
kind of changing and shaping our world
if you will and yet
it's
it's you know
its public perception is close to zero
psychokinesis what is it andy jacobson
um
book number four for me that i have uh
that just published
last week is
the idea of well the book is called
phenomena and it's about the
government's investigations into
extrasensory perception
and psychokinesis
extrasensory perception
gaining knowledge through means other
than the five known senses
psychokinesis
the alleged ability to move matter with
the mind
these are very controversial subjects
and subjects that many scientists will
tell you is pseudoscience
why i was super interested in writing
about this was having come off of this
very hard science book the pentagon's
brain
um on the other side of the spectrum was
what's sometimes called squishy science
but the
pentagon the defense department the
intelligence community they are
interested in both of these subjects and
so so am i
so
taxpayer dollars are spent studying
psychokinesis and esp
yes yes i mean
this goes back by the way look all roads
leads back to the nazis i find certainly
when i'm investigating and reporting on
defense department
weapons programs and intelligence
community
intelligence collection programs
and esp psychokinesis this whole idea of
the phenomena leads back to the nazis as
well so the we're talking decades of
research in this area still going on
today but the original programs came
from the idea that um
after the war we had a
intelligence collection unit called
operation al sauce it actually began you
know in the end when the war was still
going on
and we sent our sort of finest
scientists to try and capture
nazi technology and we did and this is
the link between all of my books
um
so
one of the cache of documents that we
found this links up to the book
phenomena
is
was part of heinrich himmler's science
organization organization which was
called das ananerbe
and within that organization himmler was
investigating extrasensory perception
psychokinesis map dowsing
and when we got these documents they
became very
interesting to a lot of individuals in
the military intelligence community
particularly because guess who got the
other half of the documents the russians
so anything
that
we knew they had as well
we were worried about who would win the
race and that is how the psychic arms
race really began
same way
the you know over in the hard science
department you had the the rocket uh
arms race that idea of getting man into
space began with captured nazi documents
v2s and scientists literally von braun
was your career arc to be a historian
talking about national security affairs
not at all i mean fate and circumstance
kind of intervene in one's own life
i think that's why it's such an
interesting
um concept for me to write about about
how
uh you know
circumstance has a role in
the path that one one is on i wanted to
be a novelist when i was younger
and i went away to boarding school with
a
typewriter when i was 15 and i was going
to be the great american novelist and
you know
decades passed and that was not the case
and i
one of my mentors said to me
stop making things up
pursue the truth
it's the truth that matters
she also pointed out that i had a little
difficulty following direction
and that if i worked with an editor
at a newspaper
or a magazine i would you know
learn how to follow direction and that
was exactly what i did it was
extraordinarily helpful for me and i
tell anyone who's interested in you know
having struggling with writing to do
that because
if you have if you're willing to take um
criticism about your work and and work
with very smart individuals who can help
you
you know streamline your ideas and pull
out what's really important and send you
on other paths and suggest you interview
different people
that becomes
i think
an enormously powerful journey when you
bring other great minds into the mix to
kind of direct you
and then you kind of wind up where
you're headed at least that's my
experience well andy jacobson how did
you get started on area 51
well that was fate and circumstance um
intervening i i i also think luck comes
into play you know and what was
interesting writing the book on
um
extrasensory perception and
psychokinesis is a lot of
a lot of the scientists who lean toward
let's say the supernatural um
talk about luck and they talk about
coincidence and they say these are these
these fall into that category believe it
or not of extra sensory perception it's
kind of intuition it's a very squishy
science concept to think about but i
like thinking about it particularly
because of this question that you
brought up so
how does one get a lucky break okay
you could say fortune favors the
prepared mind if you're always you know
reading and writing and thinking and
working on subjects that are of interest
to you then
circumstance intervenes and you are on
your way but specifically
with area 51 i was at a a
dinner party
um
with seated next to a gentleman named ed
lovick who i had known for
five six seven eight nine years he was
sort of a distant family member
always under the impression that he was
an aircraft designer because i knew he
worked for lockheed
and he leaned over to me one day and
this must have been 2007 or eight and he
said
boy have i got an interesting story for
you at the time i was reporting on
terrorism he said he read was reading
what i wrote and enjoyed reading it
so what was this interesting story you
know and he said the cia just
declassified
my life's work i invented stealth
technology or rather i was the team that
was sort of the physicist that led the
team
and this goes back to when eisenhower
was president and so as you can see this
is a remarkable lead for a reporter to
get i mean i went to the cia and of
course you know lo and behold they had
just declassified this
uh aircraft program called oxcart
that took place out at area 51. and so
in then i began to work with luvek
um talking to him about his role the
science and technology role in building
this incredible aircraft and i learned
very quickly aha there's a backstory to
this backstory and there's a lot of
tangents that are super interesting and
they're all going to fall on the axis of
area 51 and that's how i got that idea
for that book
when did the
larger public become aware of area 51
well that's a great question i mean and
it's it's very interesting in terms of
u.s national security because when you
think about what a powerful and potent
site area 51 is as i report in the book
the fact that it remained almost unknown
to the general population
until the early 1990s is astonishing i
mean talk about being able to keep a
secret i mean i make the analogy in the
book about the manhattan project same
idea right even you know vice president
harry truman did not know about congress
or congress you know the ones funding
the program did not know about the
program
so i think secret keeping is very
interesting i write about it in all of
my books but to your question
it wasn't until a
an individual named robert lazar you
know squeaked this bit of news out which
landed on the edge of conspiracy
and then area 51 became known
and i think that is the origins of an
extraordinary amount of conspiracy
theory
that
grew out of that base and still exists
about that base and there's still things
going on there now
who was robert lazar
well he was a an interesting let's say
engineer and he was out there at uh the
base according to him and he saw things
that he believed were he was working
there yes and although people will tell
you he never worked there i mean again
you know the the the myths inside the
puzzles inside the conundrums
um
but he stood by his uh position that he
you know he said he saw an alien in
essence
um
and then you get into these as i was
reporting the story all these realms of
black propaganda and you know i mean did
they dress someone up and make them look
like an alien where they try i mean
this idea
of mythology and
you know
misinformation and disinformation is
part and parcel to area 51 and really to
all of the books that i have written the
subjects are conducive to that annie
jacobson you talk about you have to sign
an oath if you are working
at area 51 and by the way is it called
area 51 by people who
work there as well or is that just our
yes i mean yes and no i mean originally
when i was interviewing the scientists
who worked there and the spies and the
pilots and
they would call it groom lake they would
call it the ranch there were all kinds
of code names for it um
but and of course what's fascinating or
was to me while i was writing the book
is that the actual word area 51 the name
area 51 was classified when i was
writing the book it's since been
declassified because president obama
referred to it publicly
that's a quick way to declassify
something
but when i was looking at those
documents we were we were talking about
earlier the ox cart documents you would
see
be reading along and then there'd be a
small word redacted like blacked over
and if you looked at it you know up to
the light or whether you could that's
area 51 and out of something like 7000
pages of documents that i reviewed
i found two places where someone forgot
to black out area 51. so you would see
it there and it was an aha moment
robert lazar
las vegas television
what happened
well he went on tv and you know made
this claim on a local channel yes in las
vegas yes and said that there were you
know there was that there was alien
technology and that there was an alien
out there and you know people have been
fascinated with ufos
and uh for millennium i mean that is
so this was like you know setting off a
match in dry grass i mean that people
went
um
you know the story built and it became
kind of a firestorm and i think that
that has since
become a great point of contention and
why area 51 is on such a lockdown issue
because people will not move off of that
idea that there are aliens out there
many people believe that and still do
what kind of cooperation did you get
from the various government agencies
that you worked with on this or tried to
work with
every book is different i mean every
book is different um
there's kind of a dance i think that's
done with journalists because
remember the just basic job of the
journalists is to inform the public
i mean
in spirit you're really not even
supposed to have an opinion
so one would think you would want to
work with
transparent elements of the government
to also make things known but i find in
my experience that
current let's say like the pr office of
any of these agencies
they only want to present a certain
message
and that's not that's a message not a
fact let's say so
where i do most of my reporting is in
interviewing
scientists who are retired who worked on
very significant programs for these
individual agencies
and are acutely aware of what they can
speak of
and what they cannot because it's still
classified and because i also write
about a lot of cold war programs
things that were incredibly interesting
and and and you know involved
extraordinary classification measures
decades ago
everyone wanted to know about them then
but could not when they become
declassified sort of the public has
moved on
and i find in my experience that by
tracking down these scientists the
superman of scientists if you will
um they are willing and and and
you know happy to share their stories
about these incredible programs because
people have lost interest
and it's this idea that you know it's
important to know
the past
to safeguard the future
and that's the greatest joy i think with
working with defense scientists
who are dedicated patriots who believe
in what they did but are also especially
as they get older
willing to
share
uh
the pitfalls the the failures
and
the press office of any given
military or intelligence agency does not
want to talk about failure period they
only want to talk about
success and i think there's a danger in
that i mean that's a theme going through
all of my books it's not to you know
ridicule a success a failure but rather
to
demonstrate
that failure is part of success but we
must be very careful
and you know about trying to cover up
failures how much of what goes on or did
go on at area 51 is still classified
i mean if i
or don't you know is it hard this is the
analogy i mean
you know it sometimes said i wrote the
book on area 51 but
if you imagine an iceberg
and you think of how much of the iceberg
you see and then how much is below the
surface i mean i probably might i'm
guessing but i probably if you planted a
flag at the top of the iceberg that's
probably
what i reported in a 450 page book
what has been what has gone on there and
what continues to gone on boggles the
mind i mean we could talk about you know
tunnel technology for three more hours
just when you think you have what's
going on
at area 51 there are a lot of tunnel
systems at that base
things that are going on there when will
those be declassified these are the
great mysteries you know i can't wait to
write area 52.
have you become a freedom of information
request expert
most definitely i mean my kids um i file
so many foia requests that sometimes
you know
well they often come in the mail and
they're usually those eight by ten
envelopes and they say in the corner you
know nsa or dod or you know
cia
and they're the thin envelopes because
that means you open up one sheet of
paper and it says request non-responsive
meaning
sorry we couldn't find any information
every now and then you get a bigger
envelope and that's sort of a great
moment of joy i mean that's what
happened with phenomena i
i came home one day and there was a
thick
manila packet
from the central intelligence agency
um
a foia request had been granted and
there were
you know almost a thousand pages of
documents
on these esp and psychokinesis programs
that became the basis of phenomena and
that was super interesting that's where
i learned about you know that the apollo
astronaut ed mitchell was doing esp
tests going to the moon i mean the
little details inside these documents
are just priceless it
well let's go to phenomena then annie
jacobson you
visited
edgar mitchell
and first of all tell us who he was but
you visited him in his last months of
life yes
the way i got the idea to write
phenomena sort of the spark was
researching pentagon's brain i was
looking at the apollo image library
because so much of darpa has to do with
space okay it's why it's it was the
launching point of the of the
organization and i found this image
and it shows
an astronaut standing on the moon
reading
a document
and i thought
oh my god this this is an incredible
image you have
advanced science i mean space travel and
you know
proto-technology
writing
reading
in this one image and i had to know what
that astronaut was reading on the moon
first i found out that it was edgar
mitchell apollo 14.
six man to step on the moon yes so i
went to interview him at his home in
florida and i asked him
what were you reading on the moon and he
said
that he was reading a map
so i mean this is this gets even better
man on the moon reading a map of the
moon
why was he reading the map because he
was lost
and that to me is
just a brilliant beautiful concept you
know it's so
human and it speaks to what we were just
talking about with failures right how do
you define failure
you have a program failure but then you
also have individual
failure and that often leads to people
being lost or feeling like they're lost
and because i write narrative nonfiction
and because it's character based i care
about the people i write about i want to
hear their story
and how it becomes a metaphor for the
bigger story and so with mitchell when
he told me the story of being lost on
the moon i was just you know it's
remarkable i mean the the brief version
i write it at length and phenomena but
what he said was
so part of the apollo 14 mission and of
course keep in mind apollo 14 comes
after apollo 13
right the failed moon mission there was
so much pressure on them to perform
and the geologists wanted them to go to
cone crater
and pull out samples rock samples and
believed that these rock samples could
perhaps reveal earth's origins
and the moon right how i mean what a
concept you can't have much more
pressure on you and so he and alan
shepard that was their mission so they
fly 240 000 miles to get to the moon
mitchell was the pilot on the antares
lander he lands within 87 feet of the
target
and then they get lost locally
trying to find cone crater
i mean it doesn't get more human um and
they have to you know when they when
they found out they were lost and of
course this speaks to many issues of
perspective you know where do you think
you are versus where are you really um
in that airless environment they
they became confused and they told nasa
you can read all these transcripts um
we're lost we think we're here we're
there nasa's trying to help them the
heart rates are going up
they gave them nasa gave them 30 more
minutes
and they couldn't find their way to the
crater and they were told to go home
you know and so
hearing from mitchell about this
disappointment of going all the way
there
and
missing what turned out
to be the target by about a thousand
feet
you know it's just amazing and he shared
with me how disappointed he felt
on the trip home from the moon
but looking out one of the five windows
on that spacecraft he had what he said
was an epiphany
he looked out
and to him
he realized that
man
was more than he previously thought so
he became fascinated in that moment with
the idea of consciousness with the idea
of man what is man capable of and that's
why i think my new book phenomena is
really about the reaches of what can be
known mitchell came home quit nassau
divorced his wife made all new friends
and began this trajectory into the world
of esp and psychokinesis he suffered
dearly because of it some say he got
lost
that's not what mitchell thinks why did
he suffer
he was ridiculed i mean he was ridiculed
you cannot pull up any article
on ed mitchell without
kind of a snickering journalist pointing
out that he conducted these esp
experiments on the way to and from the
moon and
you know he suffered because of it he
was his all of his colleagues were these
hard scientists he himself was he's a
phd from mit
um
but
he had what is called a conversion
moment again another important theme in
the book phenomena
you have scientists physicists
individuals who have these conversion
moments when dealing with
extrasensory perception psychokinesis
and they become absolutely convinced of
the reality of the phenomena and they
pursue it you know some pursue it to the
gates of hell as i write in the book
and others maintain a very scientific
attitude toward it but because
the scientific skeptic community
insists that this is pseudoscience
because rightly so
psychokinesis extrasensory perception it
does not pass scientific method muster
the five
steps that every scientist agrees must
you know you must adhere to to move from
hypothesis to general theory the most
important being that it's repeatable
well esp experiments aren't repeatable
the the those you know pro this work say
it's fickle by nature and those against
it say that's hogwash
but i love this battle
there's a real
battle between
you know science versus supernatural if
you will and again it speaks to this
idea of
what are the far reaches of what man can
know
in phenomena uh annie jacobson you quote
some government documents though saying
we cannot not prove
that this is not real i mean in a sense
there's some doubt there
i i mean there's doubt absolutely
there's doubt everywhere but you know
the cia
concluded that the phenomena was real
but they couldn't repeat it but they
said it doesn't take away from the fact
that these real laboratory experiments
happened
but now what i found
most interesting in reporting phenomena
the book
was that
when i began researching and reporting i
was under the impression that the
programs were buttoned up in the mid
1990s with the kind of downfall of this
one big defense department program
but i was astonished to learn that
they're actually
back today
under the rubric of advanced
cognition okay so the defense department
is now
merging this idea of the biological the
sixth sense the office of naval research
calls it the spidey sense
but instead of the parapsychologists of
the 70s and 80s
now the defense department is employing
neurobiologists
computer technologists computer
engineers they are taking individuals
who have the spidey sense
it's just a dressed up word for esp
um
and they're looking at their brains and
they're trying to model what's going on
their brains
and then of course to accelerate
accelerate it
and ultimately weaponize it because
that's the role of the defense
department
because of your research have you had a
conversion moment when it comes to those
topics no
i mean but i will you know the harvard
experimental psychologist gertrude
schmeidler
back in the 50s created this system to
talk about
how individuals approach this
controversial subject matter and she
said on the one side there were goats
okay
goats were the scientific skeptics who
said this is nonsense this is hogwash
you know forget about all of it
sheep on the other hand were those who
were open to the idea of esp of
psychokinesis
and i would say i began as the neutral
journalist
but looking at
many of these experiences reporting
you know looking at documents
declassified documents and seeing what
the defense department thinks what the
cia thinks talking to the scientists
talking to the physicist talking to the
psychics i kind of
shifted a little bit toward
sheep like
i am open to the idea that it is unknown
that the you know the conclusions are
not yet in i really think that is
the idea of the far reaches of what can
be known
for me it's wiser to lean sheep to not
discount
not throw out the baby with the
bathwater if you will
are there aliens at area 51
let's go to it oh my goodness i mean
that's right that is that's what
everyone i mean
that's the first question you're always
asked doesn't it certainly when talking
about area 51 i mean
so i interviewed you know 75 people for
area 51 all of whom had direct
access to that base
all of whom went on record
one source
remained anonymous with me because he
gave me
what was then what still is according to
him classified information
he was an atomic energy commission
scientist
and he told me this shocking story in
the end of the area 51 book
you know it takes up 12 pages at the end
of the book and it's what
you know garners
the most curiosity and what he told me
was that
there was a program out there that he
worked on
which was a black propaganda program
to
create creatures that
looked like aliens
and it involved human experimentation
and he was very parsimonious with the
details but he was very succinct
with going on the record about this and
you know i interviewed him for over a
hundred hours and by the way
stayed
in contact with him after the book
published
and continued to have discussions with
him
and he sticks by that idea so the read
on area 51 as i tell the story as he
told it to me is they were not aaron
they were not aliens
this doesn't mean that there's not
extraordinary material that continues to
you know swirl around the cauldron about
why his information is incorrect
it's a big puzzle but i i
i really
appreciated his candor with me and i
stand by
everything that he
spoke of and that i reported in the book
and and he stood by it all the way to
his death
and welcome to book tv on cspan2 this is
our in-depth program we have one author
on talk about his or her body of work
and this month it's author annie
jacobson her books area 51 an uncensored
history of america's top secret military
base came out in 2011
operation paperclip the secret
intelligence program that brought not
see scientists to america came out in
2014 the pentagon's brain an uncensored
history of darpa america's top secret
military research agency came out in
2015 and her most recent book is
phenomena the secret history of the us
government's investigation into extra
sensory perception and psychokinesis
just out this year she'll be our guest
for the next two and a half hours and if
you have questions or comments you'd
like to make with annie jacobson here's
the way you can contact us you can dial
in on the telephone 202 is the area code
748-8200 for those of you in the east
and central time zones
748-8201 if you live in the mountain and
pacific time zones now if you can't get
through on the phone lines still want to
make a comment try social media at book
tv is our twitter handle you can also
make a comment on our facebook page
facebook.com slash book tv you'll see
her picture there you can make a comment
right underneath there and you can also
send us an email at booktv
cspan.org and we'll begin taking your
calls in just a few minutes
annie jacobson were you able to get any
dollar figures on how much is spent at
area 51 how much is spent on researching
psychokinesis
what did operation paperclip cost and
darpa what's their budget
all of the programs i write about almost
all of them are what are called special
access programs sap programs they exist
in these
very secret classification protocols
that are far above normal classified
proto calls so
it is almost impossible to accurately
say
what the budgets are um the the one of
the budgets i can give you is that the
darpa budget that's public
so darpa spends three billion dollars a
year and that is the case
that's basically been the same figure if
you adjust it for inflation going back
to darpa's origin in 1958. it's an
extraordinary amount of money for 120
program managers
but that's only the public figure so all
of the programs are dealing with black
budgets which means that the money is
essentially unknowable
on that uh subject i'll give you one
fascinating detail that i find that
maybe stands as the best analogy for all
of this so
in area 51 the one of the kind of
creators of area 51 if you will was
richard bissell he was with he was
deputy director of the cia
and the way in which he became involved
in area 51 if you back up a couple years
he got a call from alan dulles at cia
saying hey listen bissell at the time
bissell was in charge of the marshall
fund okay that was the plan to rebuild
europe after world war ii an
extraordinary amount of money bissell
was in charge of it and dulles said
and i'm paraphrasing but this is the
essence can you skim some of that money
off of the marshall fund and give it to
us for a secret program bissell said are
you sure again paraphrasing you sure i
should do this yes bissell did it
and years later he found out when he was
made sort of the director of the area 51
project remember that money you gave us
here's what it went to this is how area
51 was set up so these things are and
interestingly bissell talks about that
in his memoir so you can find
information i as a reporter find
information in a whole array of places
from memoirs to you know papers that are
stored at different archives individuals
journals sometimes the family gives me
access to them foyer requests interviews
this is the joy of being a journalist
you have many different sources you're
pulling from to try and piece
together the story for the reader as
best you can
somebody who plays a part in several of
your books edward teller
i mean almost all of them you know i
begin the pentagon's brain with this
talk about a colossal failure i mean and
again others will say this was a
colossal win so the castle bravo bomb um
i mean this was a
thermonuclear weapon edward teller the
father of the hydrogen bomb and it's you
know the average person thinks oh atomic
weaponry thermonuclear bomb same same
cookie sheet well perhaps except for in
orders of magnitude i mean
thermonuclear weapons can t one
thermonuclear weapon could take out the
eastern seaboard
there was one thermo nuclear weapon
exploded in castle bravo uh the castle
bravo bomb out in the marshall islands i
begin the pentagon's brain with it
you know from the perspective of
witnesses who were there who told me
their story when i say colossal failure
it was supposed to be six and a half
megatons
but it went out of control i mean
teller's calculation and all the
scientists working with him they
couldn't you know predict the future
they couldn't predict their own science
experiment and instead it was a runaway
thermonuclear bomb
15 megatons i mean just an astonishing
amount of power energy and apocalyptic
by its very nature
well he he shows up in area 51 and he
shows up again in pentagon's brain and
operation paper clip the whole the whole
gamut
i i mean he's he's a super interesting
character i mean many people again would
say he had hubris and that he was trying
to outdo his arch rival oppenheimer
right
um other people will say he saved us
from
you know
soviet invasion because
you know
the he pushed the idea of the
development of the thermonuclear bomb
which some of his colleagues by the way
called the evil thing
okay they did not think these are
manhattan project scientists they did
not think it should be
developed because it could end the world
teller pushed for it and ultimately won
and he was also involved with sdi
yes i mean he gets pulled into the
program um during the reagan
administration i mean he and again i've
interviewed people who swear by his
benefit beneficence and when i say that
i mean because
the castle bravo bomb um which was a
secret program no one even knew it went
on at the time
you know we we found out later that the
russians were only you know literally
months behind us in the development of
their thermonuclear weapon and in this
idea of the battle of the superpowers a
theme through all of the books you know
the u.s government
must stay ahead and what's interesting
is it does stay ahead so to give credit
where credit is due and when i was
interviewing darpa scientists who said
when we got into the realm of you know
cloning let's say i mean you've got
thermonuclear weapons as part of the
origin story and today you have you know
autonomous weapons artificial
intelligence biotechnology
bio hybrids human cyborgs this is all
darpa science science and the darpa
scientists would say to me when i would
ask questions like is this wise they
would say
well
what if you were to wake up in tomorrow
morning and find out that the chinese or
the russians or even a dark horse like
saudi arabia presented the world with
the first clone human clone you know
would americans say my god we've been
beaten
by
an enemy nation
that's why darpa exists that's why these
weapons program exist that's why area 51
exists it's why paperclip existed
we must stay ahead
of
the rest of the world so that we are not
beaten by technological surprise and so
far we have 28 billion dollars is the
figure you cite for the development of
the nuclear bomb
in your book 200 000 employees
kept secret from congress
oak ridge tennessee took more power than
new york city more electrical power
i mean i use that as an example whenever
anyone says oh come on you can't really
believe the government can keep secrets
they're not capable of doing that you
know it's a conspiracy to think
otherwise well i cite exactly that i
mean of course the government can and
does keep secrets
and then the other side of the argument
is it needs to
somebody lost to history but plays a
role in the early development of some of
this is vanivar bush
who was he
well he was the scientific director of
the manhattan project and also of sort
of so we're going back in time now to
the years
right before america entered world war
ii
and there was an extraordinary sense of
isolationism in america you know we
didn't want to enter the war and didn't
feel that we
that we needed to or should
but at the same time the president
needed to
make sure that we were keeping up
with the science and technological
advances that we knew
the nazis were making thanks to people
like
einstein who had already come here you
know
um so you have secret science that's
really where i think secret science
began
with vanivar bush and with these
pre-war
technologies
america was hedging her bets rightly so
because you know you can't start your
uh atomic weapons program
um when the nazis are working on their
triggering system
annie jacobson is our guest
let's hear from cj in marietta georgia
hi cj
good afternoon actually
um i have recently uh been interfacing
with a gentleman actually that worked
for oakwood national laboratory for over
40 years
he contacted me because he also knew i
worked for one of the largest defense
contractors what's interesting is the
manhattan project that you actually are
speaking of and he went in great lengths
about
sharing with me that he just thought my
personality was outgoing enough where he
wanted to find some of the
children or grandchildren or some of the
scientists actually african-american
scientists to be specific that actually
worked on the manhattan project and i
over the course of the christmas holiday
for about three weeks
i contacted
various agencies paternity organizations
and was able to find
five
children of some of the individuals that
worked on the manhattan project and it
was very interesting one of the guys who
is a doctor in washington dc now
said that his father kept journals and
we're going to be meeting with him here
in the atlanta metro area in the next
few weeks
about those various things but what was
very interesting
the gentleman said is his father never
talked about his work
and that you know he would be gone for
months years at a time
and
as you indicated the secrecy there were
over 200 000 employees that actually
worked on the manhattan project
and was in oak ridge national uh you
know oak ridge tennessee where actually
i was reared and i never even knew about
it uh until i met this gentleman um mr
mentor axel who had worked for them for
many years and so the secrecy that
actually exists uh both with the uh the
area 51 project you know a great
national laboratory in others across the
united states
is so mind-boggling to me
uh it just
it you know we're here you know years
later finding out about all these secret
projects and things that happen but it's
a lot of that and we will never know
about it unless there were journalists
like yourself man that actually bring
these things up that what's going on and
oftentimes we're not aware why the
united states are going into debt
because of these type of projects
thank you cj thank you
any comment for her i mean it's it you
know you've touched upon a very
important theme for
this not only the individuals who work
on their programs but their families and
it's why i love tracking down and
interviewing the children
um if the if the parents have passed the
scientists because you can kind of get a
sense of that secrecy the children knew
nothing in many cases and also the wives
knew nothing but a lot of times they
have um and will share you know father's
papers that are stored in the attic and
so that becomes this idea of legacy i
think is very interesting and i
particularly found that when i worked on
paperclip and i went to germany and
interviewed the children of some of
these major nazis who worked for hitler
and then later worked for
the department of defense what was your
reception like
in germany you know what it was either
black or white i mean and that really
was astonishing it was either no i don't
want to talk to you father didn't do
anything wrong
um
never mind he was a convicted war
criminal
uh i'm speaking specifically about
a convicted war criminal named otto
ambrose who was
hitler's chemical weapons developer and
he was convicted of as i write in in
paper clip he was convicted of mass
murder
slavery
genocide sent to landsberg prison after
the nuremberg trials and then was
released by our u.s high commissioner
john mccloy
and what went back into the world and
then consulted for the atomic energy
commission i mean
when i tried to track when i did track
down his son and tried to interview him
he said my father did nothing wrong he
was acquitted
um
on the other hand i interviewed
other children of major nazis who had a
very different
take and were very thoughtful and
remorseful and courageous
in sharing with me
the profound difficulty of you know that
legacy that they must live with i mean
on the one hand the son cannot be judged
by the father
but psychologically it's an
extraordinary burden to bear
so interviewing
people who are that forthcoming with me
about
you know
the complications of that legacy
i mean i feel like that undergirds the
book
with
significance that's deeply emotional
sixteen hundred nazi scientists or so
came over via operation paper clip
how deep did their tentacles go here in
this country
i mean they were in every weapons
program that
we were financing there was a a top nazi
i mean that's a gross generalization but
i think it is also very accurate
certainly from my reporting i mean in my
book i focus on 21
of the nazis who i found to be extreme
cases extreme meaning
they during the war they worked directly
with hitler
himmler
um you know spear
and so
when you when you think about that then
they were working for us with us
um that's real drama in there so i
looked at 21. but there are 1600 and
just from looking at those big files and
sort of mapping out where everyone went
yes they were in every one of our
weapons program and i think i read that
one of those nazi scientists was the
first director of the kennedy space
center
kurt davis
um you know they still give out the kurt
davis award to kind of the most
innovative thinker in this
world and i i was shocked to find out
this because of the the documents that i
was able to get from a freedom of
information act
indicate that
deb debuss was a hard core nazi i mean
he even wore the ss uniform to work in
nazi germany he turned in a colleague
ratted out a colleague for saying mean
things about hitler literally and this
guy got picked up by the gestapo and you
know we're giving him an award i mean
this kind of thing is astonishing i
called up the head of the of the of the
organization that gives that award and
you know he's very defensive and he said
debus was a great innovator and he you
know brought did all these things for
the apollo program and i said
but what do you say to the person who
says to you he was a nazi
and his response was very interesting he
said
no one's ever asked me that question
before
so we have journalism to present the
facts and let people decide what they
think about those facts was it known
contemporarily that he was a former nazi
and now he's running the kennedy space
center or
a lot of these guys was that known very
important question absolutely not and
from the declassified documents
i learned that
not only
did nasa know
about their past but they were complicit
in making sure
that this did not get out this was a
this was a kind of a quote from one of
the von braun documents because von
braun because he was so high-profile
warner von braun yes he was always being
kind of pulled into it by journalists
who would ask him questions about his
nazi pass he was told by nasa to say
um if you're asked your answer should be
i've been thoroughly investigated by the
u.s military and he had been thoroughly
investigated
they just didn't reveal what the
investigation had found
so you were able to make some inroads in
germany have you been to darpa's
headquarters here in the washington area
have you actually set foot
in area 51 i have not been to darpa's
headquarters they're very secretive
about letting anybody in there
i mean they
like to present
the idea that they are a beneficent
organization
and you know they do do some great
things we have the internet um the
results of a lot of their work
have profoundly impacted society and
made it easier for a lot of people but
let's face it darpa's
job
as was indicated in its early mandate
you know in 1958 is to create vast
weapon systems of the future so darpa is
very you know
secretive about um
letting anyone in and and seeing what's
really going on
um area 51
no journalist has ever been there
including me
i was taken by a group of
former manhattan project scientists when
they were still alive
um
to the neva what was then called the
nevada test site which is you know all
the other areas areas 1 2 10 15 20 that
align with area 51 area 51 sort of over
the hill and you're on ticaboo
peak
yes and well no i was actually in the
test site which is where all the bomb
craters are and you're kind of driving
through the desert and you see where you
know a an old safe
was blown up like a big giant bank safe
to try these were parts of the test to
see
what would survive a small nuclear blast
train tracks you know the rubble that's
out there in the desert uh is remarkable
the area is all you know concealed um so
i went there and i kind of saw area 51 5
miles away but that's the closest i got
to
travis is calling in from eureka
california hi travis you're on with
author annie jacobson
hello good afternoon
i'm interested in remote viewing and
what if any evidence that you researched
did you find to be
the most convincing
uh in favor of it being you know a fact
so thanks for the question remote
viewing for those who might not know um
is another word for extrasensory
perception and it was a term created by
the cia
in the 1970s to destigmatize
the concept of esp the concept of
psychics of psychic functioning
it became part and parcel to all of the
programs that went on for the next 25
years
across the cia across the department of
defense over at dia which is the defense
intelligence agency
and as i write in the book phenomena
there's there are extraordinary success
stories of remote viewing locating
hostages locating downed aircraft
there are also colossal failures
and again i tell both of those stories
in the book and i let you decide but
when you look at the facts of what some
of these psychics were able
to accomplish were able to see
to know the unknowable
with a cia or defense department handler
sitting with them inside of what is
usually a faraday cage an electronically
shielded room so there's no way they
could be getting information uh any
other way other than this mysterious
sixth sense which no one has been able
to explain
so i would say the remote viewing
success stories
exist
and i write about them in the book
the pentagon's brain was a finalist for
the pulitzer
and this email comes in from chris
in houston texas
and he or she asks how does darpa search
make its way from being purely military
to something a company can sell to the
public at large
great question so let's talk about gps
okay
i mean satellite technology
interestingly finds some of its origins
at area 51. uh richard bissell who we
talked about earlier the the sort of
mayor of area 51 along with uh dr bud
weilon
who i interviewed for the book they were
working early satellite technology as
they were running these airplane
technology programs they were also
experimenting with satellites hoped it
would work i mean think about that as a
concept in terms of innovation our whole
military runs you know with the
satellite system being at the center but
in the 50s and 60s these ideas were just
coming online and there was a mandate
over at the defense department to
you know create what we now know as gps
through satellite technology and it took
decades to really come to fruition
but when darpa finally was able to make
these systems work and this is kind of
at the end of the vietnam war
this was an import it was a military
targeting technology gps that you have
in your smartphone okay and it was kept
secret um it had an offset by a couple
hundred feet so if anyone hacked into
our system they wouldn't be able to
target you know their bombs would be off
in essence
and it was kept secret all the way
through the 90s and during the clinton
administration
word came down that a european
civilian organization was going to
develop gps for the consumer and that is
why the clinton administration
declassify gps technology because we
wanted america to be able to be the
innovators and the primary drivers of
that in the commercial world and that's
exactly what you see
al st petersburg florida good afternoon
al your own book tv
good afternoon folks um miss jacobson um
in your book phenomenon do you mention a
person named ingo swan
i sure do they called ingo swann the
original super psychic and he played a
very significant role
in the early years of the cia program
and also in the years of the defense
department program so there's quite a
bit you can read about um in phenomena
about swann he was a very charismatic
person and a fascinating character al
why do you ask about him
i hung out with him in california in 69
when i was a scientologist
and he
oh doesn't that's one of my questions
was anybody in scientology taken
seriously in the phenomenon program
and ingo swan had contempt for the
people who reached ot3 and other levels
he says hell i can do
what cost you thou hundreds of thousands
of dollars uh you know with my hands
tied behind my back
the other thing
there's two other things i'd like to
mention to you that might be interested
in and maybe some other time not on this
program i could contact you if you're
interested
but there is a study in the university
of virginia
done about 30 years ago
that has real that scientifically
proves things that
that tie in with what you're doing it
would be an extended conversation i
don't know if you want to have it now
well probably we don't have time now al
but we appreciate your calling in i
think you do have a website we'll put
that up on the on the screen if you wish
to contact danny jacobson go ahead
the scientology question is very
interesting
of course the intelligence community and
the defense department were extremely
anti-scientologists
but you're absolutely correct that ingo
swann and others in the program had been
involved in scientology and it becomes a
great point of contention and it also is
there are some mysteries that remain and
i think the biggest mysteries that
remain surround
a psychic that worked at the same time
as ingo swan for the cia and his name
was pat price
and pat price sort of um he outperfo
performed ingo swan in the psychic realm
if you will because whereas swann was it
was incredibly gifted at describing you
know using his esp talents if you will
to describe situations narratively uh
colorfully
pat price could pull actual names
numbers figures off of documents in
classified facilities thousands of miles
away
and he was so good at this that a number
of security investigations high level
investigations came down on him because
people could not possibly fathom how he
could know what he did he died in 1975
under very mysterious circumstances many
conspiracies have arisen about what he
died one of them is that the church of
scientology killed him
annie jacobson do conspiracy theorists
come to your book events
oh yes i mean i i did this great event
with uh the one of uh the scientific
skeptics named uh professor michael
shermer at caltech and this was for the
area 51 book and he filled this
auditorium i mean it must have sat 400
people
and because it's in pasadena right near
jpl the jet propulsion laboratory um
it was sort of like half of the people
in the room were these big brains from
jpl and the other half were conspiracy
theorists and you know we had this
lively
raucous uh debate
um
not just me asking questions but then
the question started going back and
forth and sometimes they weren't
questioned sometimes they were like
shouting at one another but i think
these are all important readers to have
because
i find that
conspiracy theories often have roots in
truth and i write about this in every
one of my books where you have an
alleged conspiracy theory which is
actually you know part of a black
propaganda campaign or a disinformation
campaign and again i'm able to unearth
these documents
have them declassified and demonstrate
that things are not always exactly as
they seem would any of your four books
exist were it not for the cold war in
russia
no no no they're all a product of
that
race the arms race between
the united states and the soviet union
and often china comes in
pardon me george email
i believe bob lazar said that element
115 was the power source for the alien
technology that he was trying to reverse
engineer
since then element 115 has been
synthesized and is apparently not
possibly a credible power source
any comment
a little too inside baseball for me i
interviewed lazar for the book area 51 i
write about my interview with him
um but what i think the caller or the
the individual is speaking to the fact
that these ideas these mysteries some
would call them conspiracies these are
not going away people continue to be
interested because they feel that their
questions have not been answered and
that of course speaks to this idea that
we've been talking about uh about you
know transparency government
transparency what can be known what
should be known why do we have to wait
decades to have these documents
declassified
you also write about janet airlines what
is that
janet airlines is the the private
airlines that flies
from las vegas to area 51 it has its own
conspiracies within conspiracies
um i mean i had someone contact me just
recently and say you know give me the
janet airline schedules and they stop
flying during the day apparently and
they only fly at night i mean again
these these mysteries and conspiracies
fold within one another and they don't
want to end why are they called janet
airlines and you describe the interior
and landing what it's like there have
you been on janet airlines no i have not
been on japan
right you have to be invited like you
know many places uh certainly area 51
you have to be invited out there but but
what is interesting is in all of my
books
it
researching you know the superman of or
or interviewing the superman of science
lo and behold almost everybody says oh
by the way i read your area 51 book and
i was out there and then they tell me
the little program that they were on
dale graf one of the leading scientists
in my new book phenomena he was out at
area 51. i said dale that's incredible
tell me you know what were you doing out
there i can't tell you
let's hear from joel in eagle idaho hi
joel
hi peter hey great program
my father was a b-29 pilot over in
tinian where the enola gay took off
he never talked much about it but uh he
ended up at bell aircraft in niagara
falls new york
now there was a program there icbm
program
and
i can remember a picture of him and
warner von braun
uh eventually bell got into the x100x2
programs
but
you never heard i never heard much about
whatever happened to von braun
after he was at bell bell was uh
the bell helicopter plant of course
but um
what can you tell me about werner von
braun and where he ended up and what he
ended up doing thank you sir
it's a great question and there's
another uh
former nazi general
operation paper clip scientist who wound
up at bell
and that was walter dornberger and i
write about him in operation paper clip
as well
so
von braun had an interesting
trajectory i mean he worked all the way
through
uh the apollo program and then
retired and went into
um private enterprise and then he was
stricken with cancer and died um
but you know von braun comes up in every
one of my books there's a fascinating
story uh where he loops in with the
in the in the book that i've just
written phenomena with uri geller
of all people who you know was a cia
asset
and who got the had the defense
department very concerned with
psychokinesis so
spoon bending what geller does and many
people tell you that he's a magician
the dod did not think so the cia did not
think so
and they were concerned that what geller
could do with psychokinesis
was
think of the delicate electronic system
in an icbm
they were concerned if geller could bend
a spoon with the tip of his finger
that hit using his mind he could do the
same he could disrupt
the electronic system and so
when he came to the united states he met
with warner von braun
and uh there's a photograph i have of
the two of them in phenomena but von
braun
was fascinated with geller geller got
von braun's watch to stop and he made
this statement like i have no scientific
explanation for how he did this and
geller got an old
desk calculator that von braun had that
was that had stopped working
geller got it to start working just by
touching it and you know this mystified
von braun and because he was such a
powerful figure in the science community
it raised a lot of eyebrows that von
braun
was uh you know taken with geller
uh we had on this program a year or two
back uh jonathan ronson john ronson who
uh
the men who stare at goats
does that tie into some of the things
that you write about in phenomena it it
does i mean that's the remote viewing
program and
one of the things that i demonstrate you
know
over time happened with the phenomena
program was that the cia was under the
impression
that this talent okay which was still in
the hypothesis stage this you know let's
call it enhanced intuition or enhanced
perception the cia doctors
believed that it's biological that it's
individualistic that
use the mozart analogy think of how i i
know i cannot sing in the shower and
then you listen to mozart's amazing
music
and you know wow that's different that's
biology okay
um
that's the metaphor that the cia used
because they believed that individual
people ingo swan pat price uri geller
had some kind of extraordinary gift
that the rest of us didn't
the defense department took a different
approach
they believed that
soldiers could be trained to become
psychic
and grave problems arose
because the cia advised against this
uh the defense department pursued it
and it led to a lot of program a lot of
problems within these programs because
in many cases you had
soldiers
you know trying to be psychic
and having very little success and at
the same time you had
individual people who were actually
psychic if you will
working on these programs and having
success and it created a catch-22
because
the defense department didn't want to
believe that people were psychic because
it flew in the face of science
a lot of corporations are involved in a
lot of your books and a lot of this work
the rand corporation raytheon vanver
bush i believe was the founder of that
raytheon corporation
a lot of money to be made on these
projects
you know this is a
very
important subject um defense contracting
um
it speaks to what eisenhower said on his
farewell speech about the
military-industrial complex
and the warning area that i saw
was when i was reporting the pentagon's
brain
and i learned that the jason scientists
okay so now if you want to talk
conspiracy i mean the jason scientists
come up in everybody's
in all the world of conspiracy who are
the jasons so they are allegedly this
you know before i interviewed a lot of
the jasons
uh
one idea is that they're kind of the
illuminati of the defense science world
so i interviewed marvin goldberger who
everyone calls murph
right before he died who was the founder
of the jasons and worked on many of
these darpa projects
for decades and the jason scientists
what i found to be most interesting was
they were
full-time professors
you know at the great universities
across america
and part-time defense scientists so they
would get together
in the summers and solve for darpa
whatever conundrums darpa was facing
they were called the superman of science
and what i learned
in the recent era in the modern era is
there has been a shift and the defense
department darpa in particular has kind
of moved the jason scientists to the
side they still consult but they're not
as important i was told and what is
important now in terms of um setting
you know setting policy and making
decisions about what science projects
will be pursued in the future is an
organization inside the pentagon called
the defense science board the dsb
and
as i write very specifically in the
pentagon's brain if you look
at the individuals who are on the
defense science board they are almost
all
full-time defense contractors
they are not
part-time defense scientists and so what
you have is
what eisenhower warned us against which
is the very people who are deciding
which weapon systems which vast weapon
systems of the future
the pentagon will pursue
are the same individuals who stand to
make an extraordinary amount of money on
those weapon systems who runs darpa
today do you know darpa is director-less
at the moment um but darpa is really
managed by these
120 program managers
as i said earlier three billion dollars
in the hands of a hundred and twenty
program managers they have extraordinary
power to stop and start programs they
look outside of the military
establishment as well and work with
universities in research labs so
profoundly innovative i mean this is the
true definition of blue sky research
darpa leads the question is you know
do we like where they're leading us and
the answer is you don't have a need to
know about that because most of the
really intense programs that darpa is
working on artificial intelligence
autonomous weapons these are classified
programs
jake in west hollywood california thanks
for holding you're on with author annie
jacobson
hi thanks for taking my call
i was just wondering
you're talking about money now is there
any mechanism by which uh
the united states gets money from the
companies that use
darpa's innovations
because i know uh if you read the
biography of steve jobs or
bill gates or any of these people they
always have a stop off at darpa
i know uh properly developed the screen
for the
smartphone things like that so are we
making deals where we get paid for that
stuff
thank you
well the way the money flows from darpa
is it flows out of darpa into
the
hands of the
laboratories that are developing
the weapons programs so yes
you know if if apple has a product
that darpa wants to develop they would
be paid does that answer the question
he is he is gone
so let's hope that that does answer the
question i think he's looking for is
there a return on this investment in a
sense
well i would say the return on the
investment happens in the civilian
sector i mean if you make a product if
you
if you
let me maybe give a better example so i
interviewed for the pentagon's brain
some scientists who were working down at
uc irvine on limb regeneration okay
this is the idea think of the salamander
loses its tail it grows back okay
these scientists believe that humans
will one day be capable of regenerating
their own limbs extraordinarily
interesting to darpa in terms of you
know
you know wounded warriors um
but this kind of research is
20 30
years out
what the scientists at irvine told me is
who's going to fund that
no one except for darpa so
darpa is willing to invest in
very early laboratory research
that leads to extraordinary new things
the scientists that i'm that i spoke to
and that i write about in the book
working on this program we're very
grateful for this funding from darpa
because it allows them to continue their
research and to seek grants elsewhere so
there is a give and take in this world
that has to do with money coming in and
new programs going out
one of the characters in the pentagon's
brain
michael goldblatt
who is he
well goldblatt was the individual who
really took
biological science uh to a new level
okay so back up for a minute
researching the pentagon's brain i was
fascinated by the idea that
the hard science of those days missile
technology weapon you know
did not involve
uh biological scientists so
that happened ironically when the wall
came down
and you had soviet biological weapons
engineers defecting to the united states
and bringing with them um the big reveal
that the soviets were breaking the
biological weapons treaty and developing
these horrific
weapons um you know mixing things like
ebola and influenza okay to create
apocalyptic results so
when these scientists arrived um and
began working for darpa
it led to this idea of we need to look
inside the body we need to look at human
biology and that's where goldblatt
enters the scene because about that same
time
computers were now kind of in the in the
in the 90s okay the early 90s and
computers are now computer technology is
getting small so we're moving toward
nanotechnology
and the defense department now becomes
very interested in the idea of human
physiology
what
individual soldiers are capable of how
you can enhance that and how you can
ultimately create a super soldier and um
you know goldblatt led the way all the
way through the late 90s and early 2000s
and there's a lot of kickback from this
from the public one of the programs i
think that that sums this up with
something called the robo rat okay so
the idea was ultimately to be able to
put computer technology inside humans
and an early prototype was the rat so
they wired up this rat
and they were able to con with the chip
in his brain darpa scientists were able
to steer the rat through a maze
well people cried foul and said you know
this is right at the edge of ethics and
you cannot be doing this kind of thing
it's only going to lead in a bad
direction
and so the programs were somewhat
curtailed well then 911 happened and
there was an extraordinary amount of
funding and now these darpa programs
today that i write about at length in
the pentagon's brain involve you know
pushing
the biology of humans in another
direction and ultimately merging
man and machine to create what used to
be relegated to science fiction and that
is the human cyborg
michael goldblatt began his career at
mcdonald's
he did he did
i mean and he was recruited by darpa
it's a it's a pretty interesting story
about how
you know um
he he developed a system that dealt with
a sterilization technology
for mcdonald's on the wake of a
one of those bacteria scandals that you
know really put the fast food
restaurants um
in in a lot of trouble and so this
sterilization technology he thought
there has to be a military application
for this
and darpa agreed with him and he ended
up becoming a very
powerful player there
kathleen's calling from los angeles hi
kathleen hi hello
uh i just wanted to speak about
ions i'm the co-chair the co-chair of
the la ions group which is the
organization that edgar mitchell started
to marry science and spirituality
physics and metaphysics but i just had
to comment
on growing limbs because as an
acupuncturist
i have
i have a youtube video of me fixing a
paralyzed dog and six treatments with my
electromagnetic field stimulator
but i wanted to comment on on edgar
mitchell
in his last two years we skyped him into
the ions convention in chicago as well
as the contact in the desert conference
here in joshua tree
where he spoke about
his career and being on the other side
of the moon seeing how craters had no
lava because it all went towards our
side but i i was able to talk to him on
the phone and asked him about uh the
evidence that
armstrong and his colleagues had run
into
aliens when they were going coming back
from the moon and when they were on the
moon and they reported this on their
private line to their doctor not to the
public line that we would hear about and
then this was picked up by shortwave
radio people that they were reporting
that they were you know there were there
were people around them they were you
know aliens they were with them on the
moon and i asked him if he'd ever had
that experience or if he had heard that
from armstrong and he declined at that
time so i don't know whether uh he has
things they didn't want to share
but i just thought that
it's such a wonderful organization that
he started and we would love to have you
come and speak at one of our monthly
meetings because right now our main
project is
is fukushima the extinction level event
and why it's being ignored and we have a
former nasa scientist who has a remedy
for it
but it needs billions of dollars after
six years and so
uh you know why are these things ignored
and um
i don't know it's just very
kathleen what is the ion society
uh the institute of noetic sciences
which was started by edgar mitchell
after that epiphany
and uh they do a lot of research as i'm
sure annie can elaborate on uh you know
up they have a campus up in marin and
they do a lot of psychokinetic research
it's very science-based and it's showing
the you know the underlying you know in
other words when i lecture i call my
lecture the electrum the human
electromagnetic laser body and that's
what we really have you know we have so
many more possibilities and potential in
our bodies
and of course this organization is just
looking into that thank you ma'am
are you familiar with this organization
so
edgar mitchell came back from the moon
after that epiphany quit nasa divorced
his wife made all new friends and
started this organization it had a
couple different names in the early
years but it became a front for the cia
and i found that fascinating um
he became very involved in all of this
and he is actually the individual who
brought geller
to the united states and he was the
front for
the cia in doing that because geller was
such a hugely popular figure they needed
to mask the idea that he was actually
being tested by the cia at the stanford
research institute are you familiar with
kathleen and her work no no no no
william is in
izlandia new york hi william
yeah hello um
i had one question a couple of questions
if you knew anything about the
philadelphia experiment and the
time travels at montauk long island and
the secret
arctic spaceships uh with the nazis and
um the hitler time bell
and the alien bases on the far side of
the moon and that was it thank you sir
annie jacobson any response for him
so we've talked a lot about conspiracies
and how they kind of weave their way
through this
this because i write of all write about
these subjects from a
cia or dod filter
for me it's interesting to look at how
these organizations
deal with these subject matters and
usually it creates great problems so
because
you're
for example in the book phenomena
if you're prone to esp if you're prone
to psychokinesis
for a lot of these individuals that
leads to other ideas that are
along the lines of what the the readers
the caller was talking about
and as i report in the book it became a
real problem at dod because they didn't
know how to set ground rules like you
can think and talk about aliens but it
has to occur at home outside of the
military environment
and instead you had a couple of these
individuals these soldiers who
were using
government time government money to
conduct their own experiments
using remote viewing using esp to try to
you know do all these uh
sort of ideas of the caller's talking
about and locate aliens around the world
and you know the declassified documents
on this are fascinating because
dod did not know how to put a lid on
this because they were concerned
um
i don't know if it was upsetting people
or they just didn't and so it created a
colossal problem and ultimately it kind
of led to the downfall of the program
harry stephensville montana email two
questions
are you aware of magicians both retired
and working that actively debunk
paranormal phenomena for the benefit of
the public at large
yes and i write i write about them in
the book because uh phenomena in
phenomena because it's important to
address both sides of the aisle on this
issue you know there's no doubt that
magicians can bend spoons using
pre-digistation that's what they call it
i mean you can watch a million youtube
videos demonstrating exactly that the
question is whether or not uri geller or
someone like him
can bend a spoon
not using a
magic trick and i write at length about
that debate that battle that is science
versus supernatural at its heart
second question from harry in
stevensville montana are you aware
of the james randy educational
foundation's offer to pay one million
dollars to anyone who can exhibit any
paranormal phenomena under controlled
conditions if so have you talked with mr
randy yes i interviewed randy for the
book um
you know
i
am fascinated by because i write about
war and weapons i'm fascinated by
battles and feuds both personal
political uh global and
randy and uri geller
had this decades-long battle over this
subject
and you know they both
all these decades later stand by their
ideas
one says this is hogwash the other says
this is a biological talent so
the reader might be interested to
see that debate play out as it does in
phenomena hopefully from a neutral point
of view
you know showing different declassified
documents on the subject showing what
the dod thought of randy what they
thought of geller what they were saying
how they all played a role because
their their feud elevated all of this to
a to a public dialogue so that is
interesting also because here they are
making this an issue and the defense
department and the cia are trying to
keep it all secret let's hear from bob
in overland park kansas bob you're on
with author annie jacobson on book tv
hi peter great to talk to you again and
i really am interested in the annie's
book i uh got up to chapter 11. uh
i'm i'm really interested in a couple of
threads that you have in there one is
the early research that was done in
psychedelics in relation to psychic
ability
the other thing is the degree to which
there was something of an arms race
between the russians and and the
americans in terms of trying to figure
out how you could explore the military
uses of remote viewing psychic research
etc the other thing is i i
used to live in california and met
russell targan
and
was fascinated with his work in remote
viewing did you have an opportunity to
interview him for
your book and then i have another thing
i'll just leave you with and and since
you have done a lot of investigative
reporting with darpa initiative you
mentioned earlier that edward teller has
his
feet and so many different strands well
there's a new thing that has been
emerging uh in terms of geoengineering
and it was edward teller that came up
with the first concept for geo
engineering in terms of how could we
possibly mitigate the effects of emp
with maybe doing aerosolization of of
metallic substances and aerosols in the
atmosphere which are now
being touted as possible solutions to
mitigating climate change and the
effects of global warming let's hear
from annie jacobson thank you bob
so
your first question is super interesting
to me because it speaks to the origins
of
uh
the psychic program and again it pulls
from that original cache of
nazi documents that were discovered
by operation al sauce after the after
the war
so one of the early ideas that the cia
was following with
um
psychokinesis with esp had to do with
psychopharmacology which is a fancy name
for drugs
um this pulled from an old aztec legend
of hallucinogenic mushrooms
the idea that the shaman
um would take hallucinogenic mushrooms
and their divinatory powers would be
enhanced so they'd be able to tell you
what was happening what was going to
happen in the future
or tell you who stole your donkey okay
so it had like prophecy and intelligence
collection this got the cia's attention
and they hired a man a medical doctor
who was at the army chemical center
named andrea pujarik
and you know he has a foot in many
conspiracy theories as well because he
was a
someone who worked on the mk ultra
programs so again these themes weave
through all of my books with elements of
truth yes there really was a program
that the cia ran
mk ultra sub project 58
that sought to
pursue
hallucinogenic mushrooms for
intelligence collections purposes
one of the details i find fast i found
fascinating on this on this subject was
that the cia sent a one of its
scientists to the this is in 1953
to one of the largest mushroom growers
in america made a secret deal with them
and said you know and the plan was
didn't reveal to the mushroom grower but
that we were going to find these
hallucinogenic mushrooms in mexico and
then bring them back to the united
states and farm them and do all these
you know the volume of the experiments
that the cia intended
seemed pretty significant based on these
documents but of course
the program the scientist who led this
mission he was a of all things a banker
from j.p morgan named wasson and he
he
after he came back from mexico with
these hallucinogenic mushrooms he wrote
a
huge magazine article about it with in
time magazine
and
blew the cover on the program so the
cia's mushroom program fell by the
wayside
it seems that when you start pulling a
thread in
in in one of your stories or in one
topic you're researching all of a sudden
there's a hundred threads that you have
to pull out here and you must be careful
of the rabbit hole because
um
you do go down a lot of tunnels and i
think also it's important to realize
that some of these programs um dead end
and they really do dead end or they end
others have
different incantations or get rebooted
and rebranded like the psychic programs
of today
annie jacobson has four books out area
51 an uncensored history of america's
top military base came out in 2011
operation paperclip the secret
intelligence program that brought nazi
scientists to america 2014 the
pentagon's brain a finalist for the
pulitzer
an uncensored history of darpa america's
top secret military research agency came
out in 2015 and phenomena
is her newest the secret history of the
u.s government's investigations into
extra sensory perception and
psychokinesis
and dr martin jacobson any relation to
you
i'm cure email i'm curious about her
approach to writing how does she get so
much done four books in six years is an
amazing achievement especially given the
difficulty she has mentioned with some
of her sources how does she schedule her
work what advice she might offer to
other writers
thank you for that question um that's
one that's near and dear to my heart
which has to do with process
um it also has to do with
uh early failure let's say you know a
theme i'm interested in meaning i've
been writing for a very long time
since i was 15
went to boarding school with a
typewriter and no one was really reading
what i was writing for decades and so
the fact now that i have the great
privilege of having people read me
inspires me to keep at it and to keep
writing um and i and i encourage anyone
who is writing to continue you know to
sort of follow that idea because i think
the only failure is quitting so if you
just keep at it
you know how do i schedule
my writing i mean i write full time
and i'm always
thinking about
the what i'm writing and why i'm writing
it and
looking at what's happening in the
current climate of the world
and trying to balance out what are
really the concerns that we want to be
thinking about today
and
filtering that back to
where did a lot of these
problems come from and where are the
solutions
i love the eisenhower idea
in his farewell speech he spoke of the
military-industrial complex that is
so
famous but what often gets left out of
that is what he said in the second part
of that speech where he talked about an
alert and knowledgeable citizenry
and he said that that is
how you balance
security and liberty
what a simple idea just being alert and
knowledgeable and that's how i approach
all of my books i try to be alert i read
a lot to be knowledgeable and then i get
to go out and interview
the people who are
on the ground
doing the hard work and
tell their stories
in my book so that others can read them
all right each of your books is built in
a sense on the last one what's the next
one what's your next topic
i always hate to talk about the next
topic but um
i'm actually not going to talk about it
i'm sorry
for a minute so but you you do have
another one built from what you've
absolutely been writing here i i mean
i'm going to hint at it i'm writing
about the cia
um and i i'm
it's a really interesting news story
um
do you write at home and do you write
offline
is the computer you use not connected
oh for the rest of the world i most
definitely write at home i have an
office um i live in los angeles and i
have an office kind of you know through
the garden i take a little garden
pathway and that's my office out there
freestanding and
uh it's small enough not to be
distracted
is it connected to the internet well my
computer is most definitely connected to
the internet but grisham we've talked to
john grisham before and he writes on an
offline
computer yeah i mean i'm able to kind of
not look at the internet all the time
but
it is a huge resource for me but i also
do a lot of writing long hand um
certainly that's how i begin my chapters
because i find the brain
um
the human brain
no matter how much technology we have
around it it works at its at its own
speed at least mine does and so for me
the the the process of writing
kind of is like
similar to my thought processes so once
i have information and i know how to
begin a chapter i write it out longhand
usually the first couple pages are
always written that way
do you still write poetry
sometimes
all your books are dead
are dedicated to kevin who is kevin
kevin's my husband the new book is
dedicated to kevin jett and finley my
children um look the the
the joy of writing is so that i get to
hang out with my family i mean they're a
super source of infor inspiration for me
because you know that has to do with uh
the quality of life right so if you
enjoy your life if you if you love who
you're with
then you are inspired i think to do
interesting and challenging things
what kind of work does your husband do
my husband is a commercial actor has
been forever he's been in every
commercial you can imagine such as
you name it where would we see him milk
cars beer
i think we have some b-roll of him in a
uh car commercial here it's a first
commercial ever shown on c-span i think
but he's in the in the nissan
pathfinder commercial and he does that
full time yes yes
does he enjoy it he does i mean we're
both entrepreneurs and you know in this
world we live in where you're creative
and entrepreneurial and thoughtful
um and i don't think we've seen him yet
this is the noah's ark there he is
sitting
uh driving a bunch of animals around so
and that's your husband that's my
husband how long have you been together
uh we've been married for coming up on
21 years
well annie jacobson is our guest and we
are going to continue our conversation
in just a minute after we look at some
of the things that have influenced her
and some of her favorite writers
here's a look at some upcoming book
fairs and festivals happening around the
country
on april 8th look for us to be live at
the annapolis book festival with author
discussions on topics including politics
income inequality and criminal injustice
also that day will be taping author
talks at the san antonio book festival
two weeks later book tv will be live
from the los angeles times festival of
books on the campus of the university of
southern california
and on may 20th we'll be live from the
gaithersburg book festival in maryland
just north of washington d.c
for more information about the book
fairs and festivals book tv will be
covering and to watch previous festival
coverage click on the book fares tab on
our website booktv.org
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
book tv tapes hundreds of author
programs throughout the country all year
long
here's a look at some of the events
we'll be covering this week
monday we'll be in the nation's capital
at bus boys and poets where former
policy advisor and speech writer for
president bill clinton eric liu will
share his strategies on how citizens can
become empowered
tuesday we're back in washington at the
brookings institution for vanessa
williamson's talk on americans attitudes
towards taxes
also that evening we'll be in fort myers
florida to hear former florida
congressman trey radel discuss what led
him to resign from the u.s house of
representatives
wednesday we're off to the kansas city
public library where david nichols will
talk about president dwight eisenhower's
underground campaign against senator
joseph mccarthy
that same night will be at the thurber
house in columbus ohio for former c.i.a
officer nicholas reynolds talk on ernest
hemingway's connections to soviet and
u.s intelligence services
and next saturday we'll be live at the
15th annual annapolis book festival in
maryland state capitol with discussions
on criminal justice income inequality
and terrorism and intelligence featuring
former director of the cia and the
national security agency michael hayden
that's a look at some of the programs
book tv will be covering this week many
of these events are open to the public
look for them to air in the near future
on book tv on c-span 2.
here's a look at some upcoming book
fairs and festivals happening around the
country
on april 8th look for us to be live at
the annapolis book festival with author
discussions on topics including politics
income inequality and criminal injustice
also that day we'll be taping author
talks at the san antonio book festival
two weeks later book tv will be live
from the los angeles times festival of
books on the campus of the university of
southern california
and on may 20th we'll be live from the
gaithersburg book festival in maryland
just north of washington dc
for more information about the book
fairs and festivals book tv will be
covering and to watch previous festival
coverage click on the book fairs tab on
our website booktv.org
annie jacobson you say that you are
reading or have read the lost city of
the monkey god by douglas preston what
is that
it's a book about an archaeological
quest i mean i love quest stories i
think that they're
part and parcel to human nature they
always bring in the idea of success and
failure
and then also this idea of
who are we and where did we come from i
mean the more we learn about the past i
think it
gives us ideas about the future about
where we're going which takes me back to
phenomena the reaches of what can be
known i'm always fascinated when we have
this this is the way the world was and
then oh archaeology reveals actually
it's it was a little different
do you think darpa knew
cell phone technology 30 years ago was
going to be or 40 or 50 years ago when
it was first founded that's a great
question i mean i think maybe it goes
all the way back to john von neumann
who i write about
in the pentagon's brain i call him the
original pentagon's brain and he was
kind of the inventor of the first
computer that contained its own
instructions
he we're talking in the 1940s now
in the basement of the princeton
institute for advanced study where
einstein was von neumann created this
computer he called the maniac
it was essentially like a giant um
calculator
but what was interesting so when you ask
like where are we now i go back to that
because of for this reason this is an
amazing anecdote um
von neumann was so smart i mean he was a
polymath
and he built this computer and
originally were like in 1947 now
he would his assistants he would try to
beat the computer at a numerical
calculation and his assistants
would feed him the calculations and he
would compute them in his brain
and he was able to beat the computer
originally and then one day
in the late 1940s the computer
beat von neumann
and really it's this profound moment and
right then and there von neumann said
that he believed that one day computers
would be able to think that idea of
sentience so that's like really looking
far off
um and and what we have today in the in
the smartphone you know pulls back to
that origin story i mean in the
smartphone iphone's first generation
smartphone had more technology than
nassau had more computer technology than
nassau had when it sent ed mitchell to
the moon think about that who's thinking
about the future certainly someone like
john von neumann certainly almost all of
the scientists that darpa employs
john von neumann
vaniveer bush vanvar bush
uh jcr lick lighter these are not names
that we know today lick lighter again
he's the
he's called the johnny appleseed of the
internet because he did plant the first
seeds he was a darpa scientist called
upon
um to in the jfk era
to do something about what's called c2
in military jingo command and control
okay
so
think of technology we're talking about
the iphone go back to 1962
jfk
uh looking at a red phone right the red
phone that's the phone that if you think
there's a nuclear strike you have to
call khrushchev okay
and that tech think about the the
dialing capacity on a rotary phone
and darpa was brought on board to try
and speed that up using computers i mean
at the time computers were the size of a
room
so lick glider was brought in to speed
up this c2 process and while he was
working on those programs there at the
pentagon he came up with this idea he
sent out this very famous memo among
computer technologists which was this
where he came up with this idea that one
day
people would be able to communicate via
computers i mean he was really talking
about the internet in his mind but he
called it the intergalactic computer
network and it was going to be this
symbiotic relationship between
man and machine
he planted those original seeds for the
arpanet
he left and many capable people took
over and built the internet and then you
have this today linking up to that
technology in our phones so what man is
capable of thinking about
um is astonishing what are the reaches
of what we can know what will we know
next you're also reading neil gaiman's
norse mythology why yes
well that has to do with my husband's
norwegian so my kids are norwegian um
and also
uh you know i love myths i mean i love
the idea of storytelling i love
archetypes
carl jung plays a role in my new book
phenomena for that reason the archetypes
of the unconscious of the unconscious
you know
uh these are
basic tenets of narrative storytelling
and there are also basic tenets i think
of how
people live their lives how they strive
what they strive for do they want to be
the hero you know um that's an archetype
that's part of mythology 202 is the area
code if you want to talk with our guest
annie jacobson this afternoon
748-8200 for those in the east and
central time zones
748-8201 for those of you in the
mountain and pacific time zones we'll
also scroll through some of our social
media sites and that way you can also
make a comment via social media
july 9th 1947
roswell new mexico
what happened
you love i don't i'm thinking that maybe
at home you're googling some of these
conspiracy theories probably a sheep
more than a goat oh
interesting
um look the myth of roswell is
part and parcel to certainly to area 51
certainly to the idea that the
government keeps secrets that the
military keeps secrets
that is when allegedly a
ufo crashed and the military stepped in
and you know took the
evidence away
it links up to area 51 as i said because
this source of mine
told me that he was part of the team
that years later received
the
what crashed at roswell uh at area 51
and this is where this is the origin
story of the alien myth of area 51. well
when you read your accounting of july 9
1947 in area 51
it's very believable
tell me what you tell me what you've
i mean everyone has a different
interpretation of it so this is
perspective pov tell me yours well you
talk about
the fact that there were
there was a bulletin sent out
that the air force sent out a bulletin
or put it on the news
that this was found and then they
an hour later they came back and had
another bulletin and that there were 47
witnesses to this whole thing 98
witnesses
to this whole thing trucks being loaded
child coffins etc etc
these are documented facts and you know
i mean like the jfk conspiracy um
there are
numerous people we can't even put a
number on it that
spend so much time going over
the precise details i go over them
broadly but you mentioned the most
important ones that are and i think
they're when i say the most important
because they are actually what we would
call fact checkable you know and when
you have big mysteries and
considerable discrepancies within the
fact checkable information
i think it's fair
to
raise questions about
what actually went on and why are you
covering this up
because there is a cover-up if you're
going to change your story
lose in conroe texas go ahead lou
yes good afternoon ms jacobson
fascinating two questions uh one did you
do uh any reviews of
london's books
born
identity series for any of your writings
and two do you think the current
election of the president with all his
military in the cabinet and increasing
the defense spending do you think that's
a dark cia project thank you
i'm not familiar with any of the callers
books that he talked about robert ludlum
oh oh okay i missed that sorry i could
right um
yes but i tend to read more non-fiction
than fiction um
but as for the current administration
i
attempt to stay out of politics and this
is why is because
i think it's more valuable
to maintain neutrality
in terms of political
systems agendas et cetera because i'm
reporting on the intelligence community
and the defense department and that
doesn't change i mean
the leader the commander-in-chief
changes but many of those individuals
are entrenched
and i
know
and work with
many people on both sides of the aisle
and i see their point i see both sides
of the isles points so i'm more
interested in the battle i'm more
interested in the individual quest
and i'm most interested in the outcome
well
given let's go to operation paperclip
for this but in all of your books i
think you can find this
um have we morally compromised ourselves
as a nation at times
for goals do
as you ask do the ends justify the means
well that's a perfect question segued
into the previous question and here's
why
um
when i was working on
a paperclip
my editor and i would have conversations
about
making sure that i was showing both
sides of
the argument okay and if there was any
book
that i was prone to
having an opinion about
it was operation paper clip okay
um
and i'm not jewish by the way right
because of my last name many people's oh
she's jewish she's gonna side with the
you know
um but what was
what was interesting to me is that
i did try to maintain that neutrality
and i think i may have succeeded and
here's why
um
because i tried to show also why there
was an argument that it was important to
bring
the nazi scientists here to beat back
the russians
so was it a moral compromise
i'm telling you here on book tv that in
my opinion yes it felt that way when i
was writing it my job as a journalist
was to show both sides of the l i was on
one
television program
that leans
right let's say and they said
annie i'm so glad you wrote this book
you showed
part and parcel why we had to have this
program we had to have it yes the nazis
were terrible but we needed to bring
them here because we had to win the cold
war
i could be on another show that would
lean left
and they would say
annie thank you for writing this book
you show that this was morally
reprehensible we absolutely never ever
should have brought these nazis here no
matter what you show it parson parcel
thank you they read the same book
which speaks to my
curiosity about perspective about
what how people interpret the same facts
and that is part of human nature the
the
the ability that we have to see things
our way i think where things get really
interesting is when you have some would
call it a change of heart others would
call it a change of mind
that's what interested me in phenomena
in particular because almost everyone
who
works in that world has what's called a
conversion moment where they have a
change of heart where they have a change
of mind their life changes and the
results are dramatic
i think i remember reading an operation
paper clip
werner von braun
he had a conversion but it was uh he was
born again as a christian
yes yes and again and because i i mean i
didn't interview him and i didn't
interview any of his family members it's
hard to really know
um
the re the reality behind that and i
mean the
uh
the motivations let's say because
there's no way of knowing if it was
um personally motivated like from the
heart or whether it was a motivation
from his handlers at nasa who said
listen if you pull some good old you
know religion into the mix here you're
going to be more
appealing to the average american than
the former
you know nazi scientist with a strong
german accent
does this tie in at all to the the
project over in switzerland and france
the big uh
you know big bang yeah yeah does it tie
in at all some of the research that
darpa is doing
not that i know of but you know
i wouldn't doubt it because all of this
science is interconnected in an
interesting way and we at in america the
the defense scientists are always
looking at what's happening around the
world going back to that theme that we
cannot be beaten um
we cannot be overtaken by technological
surprise that's what happened with
sputnik in 1958
they made it into space before we did
and that has never happened since
so there is good reason to say wow darpa
is doing its job
email
and this is from jim do you have any
knowledge of soldiers being experimented
on during the vietnam war era with drugs
like lsd
also using testing them with esp or ufos
etc
human testing is an infinitely
interesting and problematic area in
operation paperclip i write about the
origins of the nuremberg code
and then in area 51 i write about how
the nuremberg code was defied by
our scientists working for the atomic
energy commission
conducting human experiments related to
radiation
really nefarious experiments that were
made transparent
by the clinton administration these are
worthy
documents very important to look at
because it shows you what is possible
right
what is possible flying in the face of
something like the nuremberg code i'm
always on the lookout
for
that kind of
um
work for those kind of operations
programs i did not find any
uh
that the reader is specifically
referring to dave cleveland ohio good
afternoon annie jacobson is our guest
thank you for taking my call and thank
you for book tv
uh my question is concerning 1957 that
was the year of sputnik and also wasan's
life article with the multi-color
photographs appeared in 57 and in april
of 57 they had project 57 it occurred
right before the nuclear test series
operation plumb bob and in project 57
this was near area 51
plutonium was scattered across the
desert and i wonder if your research
into area 51
if you can give us any more details
about project 57
that might be of interest dave
do you have a why the interest in these
topics
well back in 1989 i was delivering mail
and met a man who had been in hiroshima
a us army guy i saw a tv show about
cloud samplers and i also started
getting a lot of newspaper photographs
relating to the nuclear test series i
was able to tour the test site in 1995.
and i i have quite a lot of
documents i've got from the government
at one time i was at the reynolds
electrical and engineering public
reading room down there in las vegas and
i actually had in my hands
uncensored documents i saw the names and
the rates of dose that cloud samplers
were getting that was quite a thrilling
day
so i'm wondering in particular about
project 57 thank you sir
i write about project 57 at length in
area 51 um
and it was a fascinating test because we
did do that plutonium dispersal
and i tell it through the perspective of
the security guard out there at the time
a man by the name of richard mingus
and
it's extraordinary what went on the kind
of fast and loose operations that the
aec
was conducting
i also write about cloud sampling
because
that is part and parcel to this because
many of the
test pilots who i interviewed for area
51
including the great hervey stockman who
was the first man to fly over the soviet
union in a u2
this is in 1956 bringing home
photographs of 400 000 square feet of
the soviet union that had been unseen by
the intelligence community before
stockman then went on and was a was a
nuclear test pilot and flew directly
through some of those clouds that are
being discussed here
um so again they this all
kind of loops around together the
different threads come out in different
ways and the u2 was developed at area 51
right tested that was the cia's first
spy plane program they called it eyes in
the spy eyes in the sky um
and
it was
the u2 and then when the you you know so
much of this is about we do this and
then the soviets would beat us or
soviets would beat us back right so we
built the u2 to fly high enough that
would be out of range of soviet
surface-to-air missiles well then they
built up their surface-to-air missile
suddenly you have the gary powers
incident gets shot down so the cia
starts building this new
um
airplane that we talked about called the
ox cart and that was this incredibly
secret secret project at area 51. many
of the same scientists edward lovick who
gave me my original scoop worked on the
u2 then worked on ox cart
would it surprise you today if
congress or the vice president weren't
aware of some of the things that are
going on or even the president
i wrote that in i found that out
much to my astonishment um
when i was writing area 51 and i was
talking to a source about this
incredibly secret program that allegedly
involved human you know experiments out
there uh the crossover with the aliens
and i said how come
this was not uncovered during the
clinton administration when so much of
this that these nefarious human
experiments
out at the test site became public and
the source said the president did not
have a need to know
that is an interesting statement roy
newcastle indiana please go ahead
yes uh kudos to uh c-span and you peter
and uh to uh anna jacobson and i just
have a little question here i've talked
with carol rosin that was there for a
while a right arm
to von braun
in his latter days
and i've communicated her skype email
and talking with her and i just wonder
if you know anything anything about her
whereabouts and if she's still involved
with dr steven greer and such continue
i don't i i don't do any of those names
ring a bell besides
von braun's no
where did he end up in life
von braun yeah uh he worked in the
defense contracting industry but from
my read on
documents about him
from the government is that you know
after the apollo program ended so
abruptly it was
extraordinary distressing to him i mean
where do you go from there he was it was
such a high to be
the kind of most famous scientist in the
country during the apollo era and then
you know people gave up on that program
um very difficult time vietnam war
and von braun
uh sort of the way i read it lost his
um
he lost his way and he became
despondent um and i write about that in
paperclip and then he's diagnosed with
with cancer and
he died very very quickly
greg clearwater florida please go ahead
with your question or comment for andy
jacobson
yes uh thanks for taking my call i have
a question about the current state of
the art of secret aircraft technology in
the u.s because the sr-71 and a12 spy
planes were 1950s technology
the f-117 stealth fighter was 1970s
technology and the b-2 bomber is
1980s technology that's a long time ago
have you heard about anything about
current state-of-the-art exotic aircraft
being operated by the u.s and their
capabilities and just a footnote i do
know about the air force's
x-37b space plane
one of which is still in orbit after 600
days
in space
i think you nailed it with that last
program that's one of the more
interesting ones i know about and i
write about it in the pentagon's brain
the way i would um approach that answer
is to say like if you look back at the
technology in the 1960s with the a12 ox
car and you consider
um
going 2
400 miles an hour then you know uh in
under these secret programs you can
kind of figure out what must be going on
today based on the the information that
you talked about the programs that we
know about and then you kind of
can you know speculate on what is
unknown and again those programs are
kept secret because
they are part and parcel to national
security i mean the air has always been
uh important space to dominate for the
defense department
from page 364 of phenomena
the u.n turned to extra-sensory powers
to help it find saddam hussein's weapon
sites
this gets into the downfall of the
program because you had some of the
soldiers who had been trained to be
psychic
retiring from the military and taking it
upon themselves to
offer their services
uh outside
um the military and that is that
situation you're talking about now that
led to a grave problem because the
protocols involved in remote viewing at
that time were still classified and so
by bringing
uh the this the very subject
to the public that was a press release
on that because the journalists found
that interesting
as they should um and then the kibosh
was put on that and it took a couple
more years for the program to really be
revealed but that was a uh that was a
former soldier going outside of the
military offering
private services to the u n
since
robert lazar in 1989 revealing area 51
to the general public has there been
somebody else who has done this
that's a good question not specifically
related to area 51.
um
certainly the numbers of people
interested in that
are phenomenal but
and and yes their revelations all the
time but i think
lazar learned an interesting uh
you know came to an interesting
conclusion certainly in my interview
with him about what happens if you
reveal something that you're not
supposed to reveal and the defense
department
learned
how to deal with
people who say outlandish things or
out or people who say things that they
can
spin as outlandish or you know
reflect as outlandish and so
and also keep in mind when lazier
made his declaration i mean the world
was a totally different place in terms
of
our smartphones inter
you know information is king now and you
can learn so many different things in so
many different ways so it doesn't have
the same power that lazar had
going on abc tv i mean that was a big
deal
when you put in the request to visit
area 51 to whom did you put it in and
what was the answer
i requested to go with uh ed lovick you
know i presented it as wouldn't this be
a terrific way to make transparent to
the public um
and you know their response is brilliant
i mean it's always
um true to form
uh
and they and they you know they they
spin around
the facts because they can't actually
say
i refer to it as groom lake thinking
maybe they would you know
take the bait but they didn't and of
course they just it's like your request
to go somewhere that we're can't even
really say exists
has been denied what's area 12
out there there are all kinds of areas
out at the nevada test site um and
they're divided up all of them involve
nuclear testing area 13 was where there
was the
plutonium test area 25 was where they
were building a spaceship that was going
to take us to mars
using nuclear
weapons technology i mean you could
write a different book about every one
of those areas out there
if you drive
north of vegas on i believe a taiwan
state highway 95
you go right past nellis air force base
or kind of through it in a sense um is
that where area 51 is how far off 95 is
area 51. area 51 is kind of like north
in the different direction because it's
inside the test site but nellis has
always played an interesting role
because
um
they you know there's stories abound
about
pilots who
because everybody knows you cannot fly
over area 51. and every now and then
there's kind of like someone puts their
wing into the tip of the box so to speak
and there's
kind of a report most of which is
redacted
but yes they they work hand in glove and
always have i mean that part of the
country with all these different
classified areas out there if you look
at a map between china lake and
california and you look in area 51 in
nevada
the test site these are
huge swaths of land where classified
military technology is
fully underway when you requested to
visit the headquarters of darpa which
you describe in in your book the
pentagon's brain
as being in arlington virginia suburb
here
what was the response
same thing you know they they really
want to be able to control the message i
think more than anything
and the idea is
well if you keep a journalist out you're
definitely controlling the message
because they're not in
so that is an ongoing source of
frustration i think because
i do think that there is a
responsibility
by government to try and make the facts
known and to try and make some of these
facilities
available to people like myself but what
darpa said you know which they do have a
good point they are not a laboratory
um it's just administration that's going
on there or so they say um so they were
saying go you're gonna you're gonna do
better visiting the actual laboratories
and so i did and there's darpa's
headquarters on your screen um
does nasa have an official position on
edgar mitchell and his turn towards esp
and psychokinesis
you know
they do i don't know of an official
position but you can definitely
i could in reading the documents you
could
uh get a sense of
i don't want to say disappointment but
that's the word that comes to mind um
you know they like
individuals who are part of their big
programs to
stick with the part stick with the
message so to speak and you know he had
some wild ideas um he became very
interested in the idea about aliens
toward the end of his life and he spoke
about it at length and i think a lot of
the
um
you know you kind of go where the love
is right for lack of a better expression
and so he's getting a lot of um
let's say even nastiness from nasa i
mean they brought a lawsuit against him
at one point over some equipment
so
and he's being embraced by
individuals who lean towards some cons
what i would call
conspiratorial ideas about aliens
and he definitely leaned toward that way
and again it cost him you know
um
but i find that really interesting what
i also found
fascinating was
mitchell's relationship with uri geller
because
i interview geller at length in
phenomena and i found him to be
extraordinarily interesting and dynamic
i also wound up at prime minister
benjamin netanyahu's house when i was
with uri geller in israel raising
extraordinary questions about whether or
not he works for mossad which is why he
left the cia program
um
but you know when i interviewed mitchell
he spoke so highly of geller and when i
interviewed geller he spoke so highly of
mitchell they were like foils for one
another
to mitchell uri geller represented
everything that is possible that idea of
the far reaches of man and and his
biological capabilities
and to geller
mitchell represented
um
the great explorer the great hero
because he was young when mitchell went
to the moon he was in his 20s and he
told me that ed mitchell knowing about
geller's you know telepathy experiments
and his public persona
mitchell sent him a photograph
of himself on the moon and signed it and
you know said the equivalent of go urry
and geller said this just made him feel
amazing in the in this moment of doubt
because he was being attacked publicly
by james randy and every other
scientific skeptic and really dragged
through the mud and he said mitchell
gave him the kind of you know the
stamina and the energy and the and the
hopefulness to go forward so they just
have this fascinating friendship over
the decades that i found
really mysterious
finish the story about being at uh prime
minister netanyahu's house with yuri
geller
how did you get there so
i mean
how did we get there the quest narrative
um
i was interviewing geller in in israel
and i had specifically wanted to spend a
lot of time with him because
i wanted to
i figured that
if he was a magician and he was doing
this act by pre-digitation what you know
randy and others do
magicians can bend spoons by just you
know a trick
i figured if i spent enough time with
geller um i might be able to see you
know a crack in the veil so to speak
uh which i never saw i mean i was with
him for several days for like eight and
ten hours a day uh walking all over
uh tel aviv and everywhere we went
um
i mean he's so famous he's the most
famous person in israel it seems like
and everyone asked him to bend a spoon
and he did and you know i mean in these
remarkable circumstances and big soup
spoons in a kitchen once in the in a
restaurant i mean it was really and you
saw that i saw it happen i mean it was
just
you know and he doesn't really
necessarily touch the spoon that's what
i found fascinating um i saw him bend a
pair of hookah tongs for two
uh north africans who were there and you
know hookah tongs are crafted to
withstand extraordinary heat and and he
did that you know the hookah tongs are
like this and he kind of held his finger
it was remarkable but the one situation
i was curious about and i wasn't i told
him i wasn't really buying was this idea
that he worked for the mossad because he
told me that when he was a little boy
that had been his dream so i wondered
going back to this archetype the idea of
jung right oh maybe this is his kind of
childhood fantasy and i said that to him
um i'm not buying it and what would the
mossad need you for the spoonbender
and he got angry with me and you know he
has a very big ego by his own admittance
um
and then a few hours later
we rock up to the residence of the prime
minister and what was amazing is
everybody knew uri geller i mean the the
agents the protective detail hey you
know we bend a spoon for us and he was
bending spoons and
it just had this very surreal quality to
it of like there is something going on
here that's outside the scope of you
know the journalists need to know um
and i found it really fascinating and
then of course we were sitting there uh
in the residence and then geller
disappeared into the back
and i wondered
is this how the mossad works i i don't
know it's a mystery so it makes you more
of a sheep than a goat
it makes me more of a sheep than a goat
you know i mean that kind of experience
but really it makes me open
to the idea i mean that's what
schmeidler said in those that scale it's
like
i'm open to the idea because i'm open to
the idea of
it's a quest to determine the not the re
you know to think about and and
what can be known what is man capable of
and if you think of
the world we live in now and this
astonishing rate of technology
you know jung said it where when he and
the nobel laureate physicist wolfgang
paoli were discussing esp they had a
decades-long debate esp is it fact or
fantasy and jung said
um
you can only judge what is possible by
the criteria of the age right so think
about what we've been talking about this
for hours now where we are now with
computer technology
um i mean where we are with space travel
this was
the
this was science fiction
decades ago and now
it's all possible
so if you
allow yourself to hold that idea
and not be
so judgmental against these ideas that
yes for millennium have been you know
aligned with the supernatural have been
aligned with magic
but if you can
just hold the idea and think about it
i think there is
more to be revealed
don houston texas andy jacobson is our
guest
thank you for taking my call
i was in the air force
for eight years and i was in uh at
vandenberg
for five of those years
and um
some things happened at bamberg i worked
with nasa
and but the party started doing second
half water and i met uh
i met carl sagan
i also met the colonel that was over
project blue book
and um
there was rumors that and i saw a number
of officers uh landed
on a
private aircraft
we were told they were majestic 12
people
and
a few days before
this gathering of
bips or whatever you want to call them
um
early afternoons
three ufos passed over our base
and all the power went out for about
15-20 minutes it was a it was a sack
base
we had missile silos but we weren't
a nuclear-armed missile base they uh
test-fired
missiles that would be used uh if we did
go to war with russia don did you
actually see the ufos yourself
yes i was uh i was at a dog site when
when they passed over
and my uh work partners target montelli
uh was outside the silo
and um
other people were standing in the area
uh these uh air police
were out there when
when they passed uh they didn't pass
they they came fast and they they came
to a stop
and uh i remember i looked at my tail
and they kind of looked at me and i
i you know i said look am i saying what
i'm saying or what and he kind of
laughed he said uh
i'm not sure but he said you know
i don't think we have anything in our um
in our industry that can do these kind
of things burke and i said well you know
i
i said i think you're right and then
they they angled off right at a high
rate of speed
and then they came back about three or
four minutes later
and ubered right over to the uh
mississippi sites and then they headed
out towards uh where the nasa
uh launched usually was communications
satellites and then sometimes there was
top sacred operations that then i guess
they were launching whatever
uh for the military um
and um
are you convinced on that these were
ufos
well
before this happened okay um
i i i didn't i walked the fence i didn't
say yeah we're not alone yet we are
alone but um i'm an irish catholic and i
i told a person one day it'd be ashamed
if uh you know the god that created the
universe
put us out here by ourselves all along
all right don thank you let's hear from
annie jacobson on this or did you have a
question for him
so
ufo unidentified flying object
i write about this at length in area 51
um
unidentified flying object there are two
sides of the aisle those who say
they come from another galaxy let's say
and those who say
they are unidentified flying
aircraft
meaning they are still classified
projects
and
one thing i can tell you for certain is
that
ufos were part and parcel to the early
days of area 51 because the u2 was often
mistaken for a ufo the ox cart was often
mistaken for a ufo and i interviewed the
pilots and the scientists who were
working on this and the officials from
the government who were in charge of
putting the kibosh on those reports
sometimes people who saw them and again
what they were seeing was the ox cart
okay
and they would see this shiny object
going at a speed that wasn't humanly
possible because 2 400 miles an hour was
an unknown speed to be able to fly in
the early 1960s
so the fbi would knock at the door and
you know literally pay a visit to the
people who reported these to let them
know that they didn't see anything
strange and that created its own
new conspiracy because if the fbi shows
up at your door and tells them you
didn't see something that you know you
saw now that's not to completely
disregard all of those individuals who
firmly believe they have seen things in
the skies that cannot be explained i
just think they're different sides of
the argument
all your books have been best sellers
does that surprise you
someone who spent decades
trying to get someone to read what i was
writing yes that surprises me it's the
best kind of surprise why'd you give up
on the great american novel
no one was buying the great and not the
great american novel from annie jacobson
you know
i mean i think it's important to sort of
pivot to
uh where the where the work is you know
and when i say work i mean you know
employment um when i became a reporter
um
that really changed things for me
because i was able to accept that so
much of writing
at least for me is craft you know it's
just stay at it and keep at it and
ultimately you will find
and narrate the story
a couple of your books are in the uh the
movie mode aren't they yes yes
all of them they all are i mean they're
actually in television development and
my new book phenomena was just um
optioned by steven spielberg's amblin
and jason blum's blum house
so it's amazing because you have sort of
the old guard you know e.t right and
close encounters i mean let's face it
spielberg built this genre in the
fictional world
well in the modern fictional world um
and then you have blumhouse who are
responsible for
not only the
horror
genre becoming so popular they do all
the paranormal activities but they also
make really interesting
movies like whiplash
documentaries like the jinx and
that those
uh projects are all about what makes you
uncomfortable and i think in dealing
with phenomena this squishy science idea
this idea that's the center of a battle
between the skeptics and the
supernaturalists it makes people really
uncomfortable because you know they
think one thing and then they talk to
the other side and they think that thing
i mean i find that super interesting
because we have to ultimately you know
come to terms with our own belief set
belief set but a lot of times it's a
process the amazing thing about film and
television is they're sort of the gentle
way in to many of these subjects and
they spark an interest in the
non-fiction world i think they work part
and parcel
okay explain hollywood here you said uh
phenomena has been optioned by both
spielberg and by blum
how is it that two people can option the
same product well they team up so
they're like two great teams um
and then the content is created of how
to move forward i mean you see that
operation paperclip is in development
with brad pitt's company which is called
plan b
um and rat pack
which is brett ratner's company and they
they team up so a lot of times you have
and and pentagon's brain uh you have j.j
abrams bad robot the people behind star
wars working with warner brothers
so and and area 51 amc you know with
gail ann hurd the woman who co-wrote the
terminator
but again i think these these science
fiction is super interesting to a lot of
people for my favorite theme the reaches
of what can be known so much
of science fiction
winds up becoming the truth and in fact
so many
scientists famous scientists nobel
laureates tell me that their ideas
come from reading science fiction as a
child
well george orwell was one of your
influences that you yesterday
um i mean you know that idea of
what the future may be like
is very interesting to me and and i like
cautionary tales because
you can see what you want to avoid um or
what you hope to avoid
uh
you know the idea of dystopia
is a spooky one particular and
particularly important
this speaks to the pentagon's brain
the last chapters in the pentagon's
brain i wrote about
darpa's quest to
create a synthetic brain you know and my
visit out to los alamos to meet with
those scientists who are working on that
will artificial intelligence
lead us to a place
that uh
you know george orwell would have
written about or did write about
or will it liberate us you know it's
that it's that eisenhower question i
mean how do security and liberty live
side by side and now that artificial
intelligence
is
such a major player
everywhere you know the quest for it
because of course we have whether or not
we will achieve true sentience in
machines with something von neumann
predicted but we have yet to know
but the defense department is certainly
moving in the direction
of
marrying autonomous weapons drones with
artificial intelligence
i see danger in that i see the
cautionary tale
marsha
union bridge maryland email
were you ever threatened because of the
research you did for your books do you
know if you've ever been under
surveillance because of your books
look the capabilities of
the government are extensive you know in
terms of surveillance and i write about
that in all of my books i just really
keep my nose clean meaning
um
i'm just after the facts and
i
talk to scientists who worked on very
secret very classified military programs
and they
are aware of
what they can say and what they cannot
say
and that's really where the risk is so
i'm just i mean i'm very grateful that
scientists agree to talk to me because
it would perhaps be easier to say
i can't
because they're the ones that have to
toe that line and you know keep these
ideas in their mind okay i can talk
about that program and i can't talk
about that because you cannot disclose
classified information
um period and that's the risk that they
take which is a far greater risk
i think than me as a reporter
writing narrative nonfiction
jean in hillsborough north carolina good
afternoon to you
hi i wonder if you could maybe
confirm or if you
say whether you've ever heard about this
rumor that was running around at one
technology company i worked for a long
time ago and that is special forces
delta and
seals get a chip embedded
for identification
purposes
like after the um
failed iranian hostage
attempt
they they got remains back and
after that they decided they needed to
do that to put chips into those guys so
they can
maybe identify remains easier
thank you sir
the chipping
technology is very controversial i mean
yes there's the chips in the body for
identification purposes i mean civilians
do that as well so
but there's also the chip in the brain
um programs that i write about in the
pentagon's brain that i think are far
more of concern
and again they're
they're presented by darpa under the
rubric of warrior wellness under this
idea that brain wounded soldiers can you
know have a chip in their brain and it
can they can work on these programs to
you know in
bring back some some cognition
um but this is a very slippery slope
area and even the jason scientists who
i uh interviewed
advised the pentagon not to go in that
direction for fear of and this was an
exact quote it could lean to it could
lead to
you know
high quality brain control
and
when you have a
again that cautionary tale idea when you
have a warning
from a group of scientists who have been
advising the pentagon for decades
and the pentagon chooses to ignore that
i think it's important that those facts
be known and then the citizenry can
decide whether or not they think this is
a good idea putting chips anywhere in
people's bodies
but on the flip side then
what if the russians what if the chinese
are working on this and we don't want to
be caught
technologically surprised
and that's always the argument so you
really have to say is who's pushing the
science where and why right and yes
darpa uh is is absolutely
you know
on the cutting edge of all these
technologies but the russians also have
a darpa and so does so do the chinese
paul huntington beach california annie
jacobson is our guest we have about 15
minutes left
thank you very much for putting me on
i have a number of questions
the first question is
bob lazar and i'm sure you've discussed
bob lazar
the interesting thing is that by
coincidence lazar was hungarian
and apparently dr teller
recommended that he work on the reverse
engineering
of
alien craft
so i wonder if you've already discussed
that or whether you'd like to discuss it
item number two
um i visited wright patterson air force
base last year
and of course the
roswell incident uh involved
as the removal of debris initially to a
special hangar then right paterson air
force base
and i think from there it was spirited
away to area 51
and unfortunately i haven't had the
opportunity to read your books but i
will
because i'm a neighbor
so that's another area the third area
that is fascinating is that back in the
90s a
an american military gentleman a colonel
published a book
in which
he theorized based on his experience
proposed the fact that
alien craft
and alien reverse engineering
was largely responsible for the
explosion of technological breakthroughs
that took place in the 50s
and that many of those breakthroughs
were done by darpa
and then disseminated
through the
private sector tell you what paul we'll
leave it at those three questions but
very quickly do you believe that on your
third question
um it's it's hard to
disprove
uh because the explosion if you take a
look at the development of human
civilization
there are timelines when uh major
discoveries are made
archimedes
aristotle
the euclidean theorem you've got isaac
newton but the huge concentration
uh in a three decade period
of
explosive discoveries
simply
is statistically
out of the
norm of human evolution at least i
certainly feel it is because
we're looking at computing we're looking
at bioengineering we're looking at the
discovery of the transistor we're
looking at the tremendous proliferation
of the use of silicon
and
is the additional
electronic discoveries but in particular
kelly johnson
skunk works and i'm sure you're familiar
with skunk works
the
aerodynamics
that emerged out of the skunk works and
subsequently
are so radically different
from the previous history of
aerodynamics
in particular the sharp aerodynamic
edges of the u2 all right
paul thank you for that and i apologize
um i think we got the gist
so many of these subjects are covered in
area 51 and uh you know from lockheed um
teller lazar
again these are all ideas if you think
about going back to what we were just
talking about what is possible in any
age okay the idea of
um
strange things in the sky has been
an issue that people have thought about
and contemplated and created art about
going back to pre-civilization
i visited the british museum while i was
writing the phenomena and looked at
these the earliest examples of what
people thought were ufos i looked at
cuneiform writings from king ashburna
panel's library
omens divination rulers back in 600 bc
would say who will win the war you know
i went to the oracle at delphi to kind
of
read and and feel what it was like
to work with prophecy so prophecy ufos
man civilization biology what is
possible these are all part and parcel
to all the subjects i investigate and i
just love the fact that
there are ideas that exist and we look
as journalists we go into the
documentation we interview people we
present the stories as best i present
the stories that i do in my books as
best as i can based on
eyewitnesses
based on
documentation and based on the work of
other journalists before me who have
laid the tracks down and so the story is
always evolving and changing and
transforming but ultimately it's going
in that direction about you know what do
we know about the past and how can we
use that as we move forward in the
future and make sense of this world that
we live in where technology is advancing
at this astonishing rate and yet we and
our ideas
our brains
are still relatively the same
what about his point
that
all of a sudden we had these great
technological leaps
beginning in the 50s well many
scientists talk about that idea of
knowledge kind of this the same
discoveries cropping up in different
parts of the world
at the same time and and that is super
interesting i mean one of the themes
that i write about in phenomena that i
did not that is new to my sort of you
know works if you will um speaks a
little bit to the reader's question and
to your point and it has to do with this
idea of where does inspiration come from
okay the eureka moment
and i'll tell a story about the great
charles townes and what he told me in
our interview now charles towns won the
nobel prize in 19 in the early 1960s for
the laser okay arguably one of the most
important technological inventions of
the modern era
i mean military applications laser
weapons civilian use eye surgery the
laser printer
and i bring this up because the
scientific skeptics always go crazy on
this idea and on balance when you think
that the idea i'm about to tell you
comes from charles towns
okay it kind of puts things in
perspective so
i asked him to confirm with me
a kind of story that was out there about
him that the idea of the laser came to
him
while he was sitting on a park bench
and he said yes that is right that was
his eureka moment
now towns we learn
is a man of faith
so that eureka moment to him in his view
of the world and in his perspective
was
something that came to him from the
supernatural okay and
this
i think speaks to the the caller's
questions about where are these ideas
coming from and some people the sheep
will tell you
that
great moments are not limited to you
know i came up with this idea myself
sitting at my desk they often there are
three nobel laureates i write in the
book who all talk about these eureka
moments and who believe that these ideas
come from without and i think the whole
world and the narratives of aliens and
higher intelligence maybe even
consciousness that is touching upon
that theory that there is a greater
intelligence out there and i think that
it it's not
i don't i think it's unwise for me
anyways to dismiss this whole cloth to
take the position of the goat
and essentially ridicule it i think the
idea of being open to it is far more
interesting and far more courageous
dick troy alabama you're on book tv
uh c-span thank you very much for the
last two two hours and 50 minutes this
has been absolutely captivating
miss miss jacobson
i have a question but first of all i'd
like to tell you you just sold four
books
because i'm gonna buy them tomorrow
but what i what i'd like to know though
uh you you you made this
quotation twice
about attributing it to eisenhower and
his uh the fair wheel speech
but uh the the
the balance between security and liberty
is
an informed public
or
i want to i want to know this
and
please don't consider this to be a mean
question because i don't mean for it to
be
but just how much
should
we know
about what's going on
and we'll get an answer in two seconds
dick will you just tell us a little bit
about yourself
i'm just
i try to be a writer
but uh not very good at it
i'm not very wise
either my knowledge is very shallow i
really
couldn't
i don't even know shallow would be the
proper word of how ignorant i am about
what you're talking what kind of work
did you do are you retired
i taught school for a while but i've
been a lot of other things too
but
this has been a most most enjoyable show
and i wish you would write a bible liz
jacobson
there we go
thank you so much how much
should we know
another theme that i'm always writing
about because
when
you see some of the programs
declassified and you realize what was at
issue what was at stake
there is very good reason in many
instances
to keep those programs classified so
that the other side
doesn't
um
isn't aware of that and and then it
remains a true defensive measure
there lies the conundrum of the
military-industrial complex and i think
your the caller's question is actually
brilliant because
the military-industrial complex exists
for a purpose for national security but
if there if their goal is to speed up
the um revelations
then you also have what one defense
department official described to me as a
self-licking ice cream cone
right so in other words if you could
have a great weapon system um that
stayed classified the and the other
intelligence community on the other side
knew about it and couldn't defend
against it
and the goal was to keep us keep that
the two powers in check then essentially
you have an effective
weapon system but the minute that system
becomes known like the you know the
f-117
then
that becomes obsolete and it creates an
entire new vacuum i.e new business for
the defense contractors to create a new
weapon system so
it's it's a brilliant question and i
think it's there is no easy answer but
the the investigation the investigator
in me is infinitely interested in in
pursuing that thought and finding out
what i can
and presenting those facts to the public
this is an email from joe
which one or two
programs would you like to see released
to the public tomorrow
which one or two wake you up in a cold
sweat
i mean that's a great question but i you
know i don't know because i think the
old
really and truly the the unknowable
programs are the most interesting and it
never ceases to amaze me
when you learn about a program um
that
you know no one knew about before that
then you really know the government's
doing its job of keeping things secret
but if i had to say
looking back i think the weapons tests
that we did in space
are extremely interesting and i would
like
i know that a lot of those are still
classified because i've reported on
those and that speaks to the space race
and there is talk right now with the
current administration
excuse me of rebooting the space race i
think that is extraordinarily dangerous
for a number of reasons and i be first
and foremost because they're also
talking about perhaps a return to
nuclear testing
that's frightening and if you look at
the weapons tests that were done in
space
you get a sense of how dangerous this
all can be
merlin
ocean ohio please go ahead with your
question or comment for annie jacobson
yeah this is mr jacobson and
thanks for having me uh
i'm
95 years old
and uh
my grandfather's uh
first name was torvill
torvill jacobson
that was leif erikson's brother
so
i i don't know whether danny reynolds is
or not but i thought i'd bring it up but
anyway the question i wanted to ask you
do they the government still have all
that material they picked up at oswald i
mean that uh
uh
yeah
over in oswald the city of oswald in
roswell merlin jacobson of goshen ohio
93 years young thank you for watching
amazing you have you have the adventure
of spirit in your blood
as for the roswell remains we don't know
where they are
do we know that there were remains
we'll get you a little bit more water
sorry about that
um i mean it depends who you ask about
the remains i write about that in in
area 51 i think that's one of those
mysteries and maybe to your earlier
caller
if there was a program that could be
declassified can you imagine if roswell
was really declassified
annie jacobson is the author of four
books her first came out in 2011 area 51
uncensored history of america's top
secret military base
operation paperclip came out in 2014 and
that was the secret intelligence program
that brought nazi scientists to america
the pentagon's brain an uncensored
history of darpa america's top secret
military research agency came out in
2015
and her most recent book
is phenomena the secret history of the
u.s government's investigations
into extrasensory perception and
psychokinesis
she tells us that her next book will
have something to do with the cia that
leaves it pretty broad i guess
do you enjoy the book tour
i love it i love getting out there on
the road and talking to people
who like to read it reminds me of that
image
that we talked about of edgar mitchell
the man on the moon reading you know and
you think about this idea the archetype
of reading of knowledge um
couldn't i i often say i have the best
job in the world i mean i get to
write
books
and listen to
what readers think about and what the
experience of reading the books and then
how it influences them in their lives
and their thinking and their as they
become more of an alert and
knowledgeable part of the citizenry
let's hear from barbara in newark new
jersey hi barbara
hi speaking about
[Music]
near-death experiences and extra sensory
perception
i had a near-death experience and and i
think the brain is
is more powerful than any computer
also have you heard of dark social
it's supposed to be something where
on the internet people can read
what you write on facebook or in any
kind of blog or anything and then they
take it and they write it
and claim it as their own and then when
you go to
verify your own writing you're being
told that you're be you're plagiarizing
yourself
now hey barbara before you you go you
talked about near-death experiences what
was yours
um i fell on concrete slipped and hit
the back of my head
on concrete and i had no um
nothing to
prevent
my whole weight hitting just on the back
of my head
and i was out for i don't know how long
when i got um in the ambulance
um i saw
uh in
i don't know whether it was vertigo or
what it was but it was
like a
jet
speeded up rocket ship speed
um
like a um in front of my eyes but it was
it was going from
left to right or right to left
and it it was like a uh what would you
call it a
um
like a slot machine going in front of my
eyes all right i apologize we're almost
out of town near death experiences have
those been investigated as well yes i
mean i write about them in the book
phenomena because
that's that conversion moment for a lot
of people where they have a near-death
experience
and they come back from that with
extreme conviction
about what they are now going to pursue
and it often has as the caller explained
to do with consciousness you know what
is the brain capable of because if you
go somewhere else come back
you certainly have a different
perspective and i find that super
interesting
medical research involved in a lot of
the things that you've
looked at yeah absolutely human
physiology i mean that's where we are
today with the esp programs um
instead of the parapsychologist you have
neurobiologists
neurophysiologists
looking
inside the brain and inside the body but
the body and working to map
the human brain
is a remarkable concept
particularly when you put the military
in the mix because the military is
working to enhance
human functioning enhance
cognition
and ultimately to weaponize these
systems are there civilian applications
like all things there is dual use
for the last three hours annie jacobson
has been our guest on book tv thank you
thank you
c-span where history unfolds daily